okay 10 a.m and I've been here the whole
time
all right
we're going to uh going to convene this
uh public hearing of the house election
law committee we'll start off with the
pledge uh representative Lane would like
to redeem yourself
look at that all right
um first up on the docket is HB 243
relative to the tabulation of votes and
elections to be done in public
who is here to present HB 243s
representative catab I don't see anyone
here
um it's a Republican bill
um representative wood can you do us the
honors of introducing HB 243
okay
people never voted
you do not have to take any questions
just
fire it in and move on
thank you Mr chair
okay I'm here to call Bill 243 to public
hearing
um this bill requires a tabulation of
votes in an election to be done in
public
thank you
um I don't have any pink cards for HB
243 oh there's representative catab
there's a cop we just introduced your
bill
all right we'll uh we'll do the old
do-over we'll act like we like
representative wood didn't just do that
we'll start from the top representative
you want to take a moment to gather
yourself or you said you good to go
um it's all right I'll just get going so
um for the record I'm representative
Caitlin kutab I represent Rockingham
District 17 Windham
this Bell
this is Maya
um this bill seeks to clarify that the
tabulation of votes must be done in
public
it's a bit ambiguous now so some towns
are doing the tabulation public others
are not in Windham we did not as a
result
it was late at night some mistakes
were thought to have been made and
the tabulation was later corrected
and
I would say it was a bit
unconstitutional because the
Constitution does provide that if you're
counting votes it must be done in the
presence of the selectman and it didn't
happen but nonetheless the winner of the
floaterial seat in the primary was
incorrectly changed
after on Monday after the election and
the deadline to request a recount is
Friday
so at that point
you couldn't request a recount
thankfully the person who had lost
had already requested the recount and
didn't rescind his request for the
recount so when we did the recount it
was determined that
actually the original winner did win so
this is just seeking to clarify so that
we can make sure that the tabulation is
done correctly and that we're not
disenfranchising voters you know we can
watch and see within the the four foot
rail we can watch as their
counting any of the manual ballots we
can see the vote tapes but what we don't
get to see afterwards is then putting it
all together and although the tapes are
posted afterwards on a whiteboard
the
um
calculation sheets are not my dad said
um the tabulation sheets are not posted
afterwards for any of the
um manual vote counts so this is just
clarifying that they both have to be
done in public happy to take any
questions
the questions from the committee yes
representative Lane um thank you
Mr Vice chair and representative
um
was when you were talking about the
results was that this past election or
the election okay so is this password it
was this past election
okay could I have a follow-up please of
course
um logistically is it possible I I'm not
familiar with the setup at Wyndham but
is it possible to set it up so it can be
seen yes so
to my knowledge every polling place has
to do the counting in public so they
have to have that they have to have that
four foot rail in place
so all of the towns have that four foot
rail in place it's just a matter of if
they're choosing to use that four foot
rail to then do their tabulation or not
in my town they decided not to
they did it way in the corner of the gym
where you couldn't see anything
further questions from the committee
representative Hamer
thank you for taking my question
voting machine is a tabulator
it adds them up adds up the votes
so yes for for the for the machines
that's correct
but then what doesn't happen I guess is
the final tabulation between the machine
count of all the votes and remember like
many of the towns have you know multiple
machines like Windham for example has
four different machines and then we also
had the hand counted ballots from each
of the machines and the all of that so
it's the tabulation of everything coming
together
follow-up follow-up
um
when do you expect this is going to be
done because voting stops at seven eight
and then it takes time to go through
everything are people going to hang
around that long
they did in Windham I was there until 3
30 in the morning while they did it it
the under the Constitution you have to
do it within five days so they can break
and and come back the next day but it
still has to be done in public in the
presence of the select bin so
um I'm just simply asking that that
tabulation piece is also public so that
we're being transparent and that we can
have confidence in the elections because
I think right now there's
a confidence issue and we need to make
sure that
voters are confident that that their
vote is indeed counting because I think
we have many people that are like why
should I bother to go out and vote
because it's not going to count anyway
we need them to know that yes your vote
is counting it's all happening in public
I think this will give them that
confidence
representative Hamlet thank you Mr chair
Mr Vice chair and thank you for taking
my question so in Windham are the four
voting machines in the same place or are
they in different like in different
wards
Barrel in the same location
okay so
so in Portsmouth we have
uh five Awards so there are five
different voting locations so when you
mean tabulating uh tabulating the total
votes from all five Wards those would be
done at City Hall
after the
um you know after all the words have
turned in their uh totals from their
Ward
so is that the tabulation that you want
to be public that would occur at
probably at 1am usually
um so I'd like all the tabulation to be
in public but ideally what I mean is in
each of those Wards we're going to be
tabulating together the
vote Counts from the machines and then
the hand count tabulation sheets and
adding all those up together for each of
the awards and I think it's very
important that that be public because if
there's somebody in each of those five
words for example then those people
would have already known like what they
are and what the final should be but yes
I don't in the in the town hall I mean
it's required under the Constitution for
a tip for for all of the accounting to
be public so that should be public as
well
representative Bay
so um similar to representative Hamlet's
uh question because uh I live in Dover
and we have six Wars each one has a
counting machine so I think that the
counting is is public people are there
but uh given that they're all in in
different words you're saying the
tabulation is to put together all of
those numbers in one and the way that it
happens in in our uh in in Dover is that
uh the next day we see
um the the sheets that were submitted
from each Ward and to me anyway the
tabulation is online because the all the
votes are are counted so would you
consider that type of tabulation where
all the numbers are there counted
publicly so you can check whether the
numbers that were put together are are
the same numbers and the tabulation is
online it's available on the Internet is
that what uh would that qualify as uh
your recommendation as far as tabulation
being public yes as long as again like
in those individual Awards they could
watch the voting tapes be added up with
the
um
hand count ballot sheets being added
together
if in terms of like combining all six
together as long as that was public and
that they had each been able to see like
hey from each Ward this was accurate
absolutely that's fine
thank you thank you Mr chair further
questions from the committee
all right seeing none um thank you
representative kutab
um next up is representative uh papovisi
Mueller did I get that
how close was I there you're gonna have
to let me know
I think Mr chairman I know it's my turn
to speak every time when I see that
chair take a couple of seconds to figure
out the name so you don't even really
need to pronounce it technically it's
Popovich Mueller but it's fine
um I just want to take one minute from
the committee I try to keep my testimony
really short for obvious reasons you
guys have a really long day ahead of you
and it will feature quite a lot of bills
that my name is on I don't know how the
scheduling work worked this is one of
the simplest all it asks for is
transparency
transparency is important to build to
build trust in the election system and
unfortunately in Windham we have had
quite a recent set of experiences that
led to town people feeling less than
confident in what's going on this
incident that we are talking about could
have changed the election result in ways
that would have made it impossible for
the person who you know was going to
lose if that incorrect set of results
would have been upheld
you know and they wouldn't have had the
recourse because they announced the
change after the deadline to ask for a
recount so it was a pretty significant
issue and for the record to this day we
don't know exactly what the error was
the town is not talking about it they
were asked and all that they are saying
is
pretty much a nothing to see here if
you've ever watched Leslie Nielsen Naked
Gun that scene in front of the fireworks
store everything exploding that's that's
kind of how the town handled this they
basically said
from the beginning first they said there
is nothing wrong
then the recount happened and it proved
that yeah something was wrong then they
said oh we know exactly what was wrong
trastas I mean they never said exactly
what they draw what what happened that
was wrong so we need more transparency
in the process and it's not just Windham
Windham is just happens to be the town I
live in
there is a lot of distrust in the
election process and allowing people to
monitor more of it creating more
transparency should be a very bipartisan
goal where we all agree we need
confidence in the system and allowing
people to observe more would build some
of that confidence and that's all I
wanted to say thank you okay questions
will you be taking questions first
question other questions
okay seeing none thank you thank you I
think there's some more pink cards
making their way here let's see if
they're for this bill or not
all right
um sorry nope there's neither number for
this bill uh are there anyone anyone
else wishing to speak on this bill
um yes
it's good to see you again I think we've
have we seen you yet this year
oh man
you're out of Nashua now right I was
watching you on the uh the city I'm I'm
the guy that watches those uh those uh
city clerk hearings or city council
hearings I'm that guy can you turn your
mic on for us so Dan Healy I'm
representing uh myself uh so our
associate our clerk Association
um we don't have an opinion on this bill
so basically
our feeling is that we believe the
tabulation and Counting already takes
place in public I just wanted to clarify
some comments made by the sponsor so on
Election night all the results are done
in public
um inside the guardrail the counting the
tabulation you add up the machine tapes
you add up the hand counts and that's
what's sent to the Secretary of State if
it's a state election and if it's a town
or a local election that's the results
that we put
the next day most clerks or I would
assume all clerks go in and they check
their paperwork they check the machine
tapes they check the hand count tallies
and if they see that any adjustments are
needed because something you know at one
in the morning
was written down incorrectly that's when
they do it I believe that's what the
representative was mentioning and so
Windham came in you know the next day or
whenever they did this and they noticed
that there was a discrepancy on their
spreadsheet so they corrected it
their votes for that night of the
election were counted in public inside
the guardrail so
I believe we already do this
in what the representative was speaking
to was a clerk noticing an error and
then fixing it which is what we would
want to happen
I know Windham had an election monitor
assigned to them and the report is
available for those I believe it was for
the primary in the election monitor gave
them a great review for that election
so I would be open to any questions if
you have them
questions from the committee
representative Muirhead good to see you
today thank you Mr chair
could you explain what the difference
between counting and tabulation is
I believe
um the counting is maybe adding the
machine tape with the hand counts
together because tabulation is the
printout from the machine I believe the
accuvote machine and then I think it's
putting the two numbers together and you
have to have the results that night you
you can't you know end for the night and
come back in and start adding them up
but Clerk's check the next day you know
for the last two elections in Nashua I
left the city hall at four in the
morning so
you really want to go back and make sure
that all those numbers tie out so what
I'll do first thing in the morning when
I get in is I'll look at the accuvo tape
and I'll pull out the hand counts and
we'll make sure that the number is total
and that that's the correct numbers that
we reported so I believe in this case
Windham went back they noticed that
there was a discrepancy and they they
corrected it I think that's what you
want to happen
further questions represent Blaine
thank you
with you that you explain why you're
changing it to or do you make a notation
or are you doing this solely on your own
so for a town or municipal election it
usually with the deputy or some other uh
office staff if it's a state or a
federal election we would make the
change contact the Secretary of State
and you'd send an amended amended
results
but you would have someone there that's
looking at it with you and you'd say you
know you have the accuvo tape out and
you say well this number when they put
it into the Excel spreadsheet they type
this wrong digit in you know the two of
you would verify that
representative weary
yes thank you for your testimony you
commented that uh Windham tabulation was
conducted in a public setting were you
there
no I was not at uh Wyndham but the
counting in the tabulation has to be
done in in public inside the guardrail
so if it's done in a follow-up yeah
follow-up please thank you Mr chair
um
so was it done in a spot where
the actual activities could be clearly
observed or was it just done publicly in
a large room
I I believe that they hold their
elections at the high school gym in for
the primary election they had a state
assigned election monitor so
um
I'm fairly confident for that election
that it was done in an area where they
could see but it would be in the
election monitors report
further questions
oh yes representative Barnum
thank you Mr Vice chair
um does the counting also include the
ballots that have been released from the
supervisor of the checklist total
I'm sorry I'm not following the question
the checklist has a final total of how
many how many ballots are given that day
does that include count as well there's
a just accounting of the voting
ballots are you referring to the
checklist
the the number of Voters off the
checklist I think that he's trying to
clarify the question for him so you're
talking about the number of people who
are crossed off the checklist
when you enter to vote
and you get your ballot they check your
name usually there's a count for that
how many ballots have been released is
that part of the count as well or is it
just the counting from the hand count
balance that number would be on the
moderators worksheet which needs to be
provided to the Secretary of State
within 48 Hours of the election so those
numbers you want to tie out all your
numbers so you count how many voters
checked in you count how many ballots
went through the machine how many were
hand counted there's like three or four
categories and the goal is that all
those numbers match because you should
have the you know the ballots that you
counted at the end of the night you
should match the check-in numbers
yes representative Kennedy
thank you Mr Vice chairman and thanks
for taking my question uh you began your
testimony by saying you were speaking
for yourself
so you are not talking for any other
clerk in the state
I I am not
um I am in
um contact with the Windham Town Clerk
and I know she feels the same way on on
this but besides that I'm not speaking
on behalf of the clerk's Association we
didn't take an opinion on this bill
um so I don't want to speak for them
further questions
yes representative Brennan thank you for
taking my question are you aware of any
instance where counting or tabulating
has happened behind closed doors in a
secret room or closet or anything like
that have are you aware of any instance
like that no and and that would that
would violate it in our sale it has to
be done into the guard rail in public
view okay
further questions
okay singman thank you um does anyone
else wish to speak on HB 243
[Music]
um
right representative
yes fine yep that's fine
I generally don't testify a second time
but it is just a matter of correcting
facts on the record
I just sent everybody on the committee
an email and I succeed Caitlyn that's
why what I was desperately trying to
type in
it is a link to the press release on
September 20 2022
which was issued after town residents
noticed the change in the election
results that changed it you know and you
can read it it is the press release that
I refer to by uh you know pointing out
to the Leslie Nielsen movie
it basically says that um
it's all good
this is just a complex process and it's
all good nothing to see here move along
it uses different language
the error was not found
it was not investigated even after these
results were brought to the attention of
the Town officials nothing was done
other than this press release
at least nothing that was talked about
publicly and God knows they should have
until after the Secretary of State
recount proved that the initial results
published The Night of the election were
correct and this was wrong
then new press releases showed up this
is all that the town saw until after the
Secretary of the State recount I just
want to have that fact on the record
because statements were made to the
contrary and this establishes facts so
thank you
okay all right
anyone else wishing to testify on this
bill okay um representative what could
you be uh tossing that blue sheet there
okay oops well that's just really easy
um one person signed in and they were
against it with that I'm going to close
the public hearing for two HP 243 we
will reconvene in seven minutes to do
the public hearing for 244 and I'm gonna
run to my car and get my cell phone so
I'll be right back
thank you
okay it's 10 30 so we're going to open
up the hearing for our house bill 244
relative to the printing of the election
day checklist representative cutab is up
again
thank you Mr Vice chairman for the
record my name is representative Caitlin
kutab and I represent Rockingham 17.
so
this bill seeks to do two things one
it's clarifying the clerk
shall mail verified absentee ballots
until 12 pm on the day before the
election instead of 5 PM
I do think it's important to note that
there are several towns who don't even
have post office open until 5 PM and so
I think we're disenfranchising voters a
little bit to make them think that a
ballot May reach them if they request it
at 4 55 pm and
the clerk is dropping it off at a post
office that's already closed for the day
so this isn't prohibiting them from
going down to the town hall filling out
their absentee ballot at the Town Hall
that same day this is just saying that
they don't have to mail them after that
point
further this is seeking to
make the names of anybody who requested
an absentee ballot on the voter
checklist
to be bold that way anybody who is
observing or or watching at the polls
can see kind of from far away who has or
hasn't requested an absentee ballot and
they can they can watch that person and
and make sure that things are being done
fairly and accurately
so
it makes it easier to audit it and it
also prevents the case of
somebody bringing in an absentee ballot
with them and collecting another
absentee ballot and putting it through
the machine if you're not carefully
watching them could pretty easily be
done right
so we just want to make sure that again
things are fair and things are accurate
okay oh you've been taking questions yes
happy to take any questions questions
from the committee
representative Muirhead thank you Mr
chair what could could you repeat and
explain again what could pretty easily
be done
so if I request an absentee ballot from
the clerk they mail me one
I can still go to the polls
and vote
and if I had mailed in my absentee
ballot they would be checking at the end
of the night to see
was this mailed in and did the person
come out to vote at the same time and if
if that was the case they would remove
my envelope from the stack and they
wouldn't count it however if I just
unfolded the ballot and I put it through
the machine at the same time as my other
ballot there are towns that do have
multiple ballots you could put them both
through what's to stop you from doing
that if somebody's not watching you
further questions
do you have a question
yes
um
well thank you for taking my question
so
well I guess I have two questions so
in our ward in our town it would be
impossible for somebody to put two
ballots into the machine
at the same time the clerk who's
standing the clerk of the Monterey who's
standing at the machine watches very
carefully so all right my second real
question is
um
it sounds like the way this is worded
that if your name is bolded for having
had an absentee ballot mailed to you
that you would then not be allowed to
vote in person
is that what that means
so right now they currently place an an
AV next to the person's name this is
just saying that they're gonna bold the
name to make it more easily seen by the
people that are observing or watching so
I don't believe that that's the that
that's the way that it's currently done
um I believe right now if you haven't
at the end of the night what they do is
they check to see if you have a mailed
in ballot and if you came in that same
day then they just don't count your mail
then ballot and I I heard what you said
about your town and I think for some
small towns where they maybe only have
one machine and the clerk can carefully
watch that's certainly doable but you
know we had Representatives here talking
about five different polling locations
eight different polling locations we
can't have a clerk obviously in each one
that's carefully watching a lot of times
they're volunteers that are watching so
representative Brennan
thank you and thank you for taking my
question on line 22 of this bill
um which is unchanged it says the names
of all voters who have requested an
absentee ballot shall be printed in bold
so
this is already happening in towns and
municipalities that someone who requests
about it
is printed in bold already and then
when they mail back their ballot the red
ink AV marks that they have actually
cast their ballot so am I understanding
this correctly that
just by requesting a ballot but not
necessarily returning that ballot
that a voter would be prohibited from
voting in person
on Election Day
I'm gonna pause you right there
representative representative Brennan
your question is very valid
um
representative Ward and I were
discussing it looks like that's a change
in the bill to the existing RSA I'm
looking it up right now
um 254 26.
um so I'll just read it just to kind of
clarify I think this is an error not I
think this is an uh it was repealed
previously so it's reenacting it so it's
reenacting it okay so I think that's
supposed to be bold in the bill in the
bill because the current RSA at least as
I'm looking at it right now make sure
before I really just put my foot in my
mouth
um
just looking at two different it doesn't
have it on there yet
it does yeah so OLS said that in the
case of something that's like a whole
new section they don't bold it they just
note that that would be a new section
they don't bold the whole thing they
only bold it when you're changing like a
small amount in it or if it's too
confusing they don't bold the whole
thing yeah so there's certain
circumstances which I guess they do or
don't yeah they probably but that is a
new that is an entirely new section so
that's a new it's a new
is it there
it appealed and reenacted
yeah they just didn't really do a good
job of it okay sorry about the reason
you want to ask your question before I
sort of rudely interrupted you um I just
want to make sure we're all on the same
page
thank you I just want to make sure that
I'm understanding this bill correctly
that someone who has requested a ballot
but has not turned that ballot in
will not be turned away at the polling
place because
you're a mom I'm a mom plans change
right so I want to make sure that
someone who has not
um returned their ballot simply because
their plans have changed and they want
to make sure their vote is counted they
show up on Election Day that they will
still have the opportunity to vote can
you just explain how this changed this
particular change will impact real world
situations yeah so that wasn't the
intention and actually the way I'm
reading it is kind of similar to how
you're reading it and I think
currently it it does say that although I
don't think it's actually happening so I
think it should be fixed and I'm happy
to put in an amendment for that the
purpose was just to bold the name so
that again when people were watching at
the polls
they could just be you know making sure
that
the person was only turning in one
ballot and yes I agree sometimes plans
change and somebody may need to vote in
person at the time and so I think
though it does read like that although I
didn't think of it that way only because
that's not what's currently being
practiced so I do think even with the
the red AV on there as well which I
think you can't see from as far away I
certainly don't want to turn away voters
in that case either so I do I do think
that that should be clarified and I'm
happy to put in an amendment with OLS
for that
representative Muirhead thank you Mr
chair
um on this section that we're discussing
which is lines uh 20 to 23
of the bill
my reading is that the current law
um well it says that the uh
the the supervisor shall make and post
copies of the current checklist
of the office of the town or city clerk
or at Town Hall
not later than the fourth Tuesday before
the day
of any state election
and this one this bill deletes that
repeals it
and says that the checklist shall be
posted
no sooner than 12 p.m on the Monday
before the election so that would be
less than 24 hours before polls open
that's a major change in in the law
and that this list that's published on
the Monday before the election
would include all the names of people
requesting an absentee ballot and in
bold
would that allow would-be thieves to
check the to check to see whose
requested an absentee ballot in order to
determine which homes in a town might be
empty and which homes might be right
targets for um for burglary
well I think that if you're posting it
way in advance that would be
kind of offering the same thing as if
you posted it soon or two it would give
a less opportunity to do so
and I I have heard from some of the the
clerks that that they would
like to allow for the posting to be a
little bit sooner and perhaps to
um
highlight the name or some or something
different in the meantime just in the
case of
having the time to prepare the checklist
and I'm certainly amenable to that I
just this this just seeks to be more
transparent in the process that's that's
the purpose of it and I you know
I do think
currently like us having that we send
them out until 5 PM the ballots we're
telling people that in this RSA we're
kind of implying that you actually may
receive your ballot and in several towns
we know that the post office isn't even
open so why would we even apply to the
voters that it may when it's completely
impossible that they're going to get the
ballot
um
I think we're just enfranchising those
voters by by even implying such so
beautiful thank you thank you
no thank you no thank you okay sorry uh
representative Lane
you
um
I'm gonna follow up along the same line
that representative mirror had had so
I'm I'm curious about the change about
not later than the fourth Tuesday to not
later than 12 p.m on the Monday before
the election and why what was the
purpose of that so the purpose was so
that the names of anybody who had
requested
um the absentee ballots could be bolded
yep
today
you have to register to vote a month
before and if you don't then you have to
do same-day election so I'm not sure
that anybody I'm just wondering if
that's why they do that I and it and you
may not know the answer to that but I
think that's something I want to find
out because it is a big change to do it
yeah so I'd be fine changing it to say
um you know instead of Bolding it if
they printed it out but highlighted the
names that would also be fine
um I just wanted it to be again obvious
who had requested these absentee ballots
and who did not
members of the bank
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question this is actually a follow-up
question on something that was mentioned
earlier about those Sinister voters who
tried to vote twice so are you referring
to actually uh bringing in the absentee
ballot that was requested to the mail
and getting another ballot and so you're
not referring to uh those people who
might have already sent in their field
ballot and showing up at the
no so the second case is already covered
because they do they do go through and
see if you came that day at the end of
the night so that case is already
accounted for but what's not accounted
for would be in the case of large
polling places
somebody putting through two ballots
thank you
further questions from the community
thank you for taking my question did you
know when Manchester has 12 polling
spots
and in those polling spots we have three
Selectmen one wood clerk one moderator
and numerous ballot inspectors they're
all there to watch the ballots go in the
machine so
how could anybody put in two ballots
so I agree that in some places they're
well staffed and it would be unlikely to
happen but that's not the case in all of
the towns having
a person standing at each of those
machines it's just it's it's different
depending on where you are
resume your head thank you Mr chair you
testified this morning that it'd be very
easy for someone to vote twice to put
two ballots in
and and I just don't understand how it
be anything other than very difficult
for a voter to submit two ballots while
the moderator clerk is watching the
machine into which you submit the ballot
could you explain again how it'd be very
easy
so my moderator isn't isn't standing
there watching he actually is sitting
down across the room
um
but I mean I guess the only way I could
show you how easy it would be would be
to put a blank ballot through the
machine and right on the top blank
ballot for the purposes of demonstrating
because otherwise it would be illegal
for me to vote twice right
all right seeing no more questions uh
well thank you representative catab next
up representative
um Popovich Mueller did I get closer
that time
I feel like I was close
it's about a 9 out of ten and by the end
of the day you will be at 10 with
practice
I just want you to take one minute to
talk about the intent of this bill
because the first question that I asked
the representative Carter when she
showed me the bill was
how can we make sure that no voter gets
disenfranchised by this bill because
obviously you are you know saying that
it's now no longer mandatory for the
clerk to send absentee ballots uh until
5 PM you are moving it to 12 technically
there is a possibility of people asking
at the last moment
so
the issue with you know 5 PM as
representative kotep said is that you
may be physically and able to do it
clerks you know receiver request at the
last moment there is no time to actually
do that and creating that expectation is
dangerous because we're putting voters
in a position where they exert their
laws it know the rights according to the
law and it doesn't work that way
um in regards to the copies of the
current checklist the intent of changing
the time when they should be posted was
to make sure that all the requests for
absentee's ballots were received at the
time when the checklist was printed so
that when the checklist is printed
everybody who has an absentee ballot is
properly marked so it's clear to all the
volunteers that run our polling stations
and give ballots you know who's
requested an absentee ballot or not I
cannot comment on How likely it is for a
absentee ballot that was mailed but not
returned to the clerk to find its way
into the you know
machines but
given the huge variety of setups you
know with all the towns trying to meet
their legal requirements it's very hard
to say that that's not possible I mean
when I vote for the town I have three
different ballots right each of them
with a different color
you know I've been known to put one in a
machine and one in another machine and
if you move around a little you know you
can come you can see a scenario whether
it's possible I you know cannot say
likely I cannot comment on how you know
possible that is but it's just
healthy to ensure that those absentee
ballots that were sent out are accounted
for in one way or the other whenever
possible
and
let's see no I think that was all that I
really wanted to cover and I'm trying to
keep it short so thank you
questions on the committee
okay none thank you
uh Dan Healy
good morning members of the committee
Dan Healy Nashua city clerk representing
New Hampshire City and town clerks
Association
so we are opposed to this bill uh for
the reason of printing the checklist and
having it available on that Monday
that's simply it's not enough time for
our office to get you know
I have nine Wards I have nine checklists
that I would need to print we start
printing after the supervisors of the
checklist of the board of registrars
have their session because it takes a
long time to print say five six hundred
pages and then the same checklist that
we would post to the lobby has to go to
the polling place so you have to
separate that out you know a through C
or whatever my clerks are doing that
over the course of the days leading up
to the election because they're also
they're giving out absentee ballots and
doing other things at the window they
you know separate the checklist
um as they can throughout the day so 12
p.m the day prior just it's simply not
enough time to get that list out there
and we have some concerns too you know I
start printing it as soon as I can
because what if the printer breaks or
what if there's other issues you're not
going to have a checklist available for
the election I don't think it's a good
idea to start printing at 12 pm the day
prior
so we are okay with the absentee cut off
of 12. we didn't have any issues with
that but we are against this bill
because
um it's just it's simply not enough time
to get that checklist printed and as
voters come in and request absentee
ballots their name gets bolded so say
you had the cutoff time on Friday you're
going to have the majority of the
absentee
requests in bold already
on Election Day when we start processing
absentee ballots
we then go over to the checklist and
make sure that the name's not crossed
out
they didn't come in in the morning and
vote before
so we we process the absentee we get it
ready and then before it goes any
further before it goes into the machine
before it's counted they bring the list
over to the ballot clerk that verifies
the name's not crossed off then it's
crossed off in red marked as an absentee
voter and then the ballots processed so
I think it would be very difficult to
vote absentee and then come in and vote
in person
referencing putting two ballots in the
machine
most polling locations have someone at
the machine at The Ballot Box or someone
that's in the area whether it's the
clerk the moderator an inspector of
election there's people watching I I
would find it very very difficult to put
in your absentee ballot in the machine
and also the ballot that you received
that day
um so with that I'd be open to any
questions
we'll start from the left and work our
way over representative weary
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Healy for your testimony
um just uh so I could be clear about
what what you're objecting to and what
you're not objecting to just so you're
not objecting to placing the red ink AV
or any of that or making the names of
absentee voters distinguishable from
other voters on that list
it's it's really the timing of the
printing of the checklist or the list is
that correct yes that's correct
um the day prior to the election there's
so many things that clerks have to do
some clerks are responsible for setting
up their polling place we have to verify
all the absentees that came in Prior it
just it's not enough time to then print
thousands of pages of the checklist and
separate it out and currently
voters that request an absentee ballot
their names are already in bold on the
checklist that I believe took effect a
year or two ago so when the checklist
prints if someone requests an absentee
ballot up until the time the checklist
is printed they would be in bold so
you're really if if it was moved say to
Friday you're really only talking the
ballots that would come in on Monday
that wouldn't be in bold
foreign
so would you be amenable to having the
additional names from or from the
additional requests highlighted or
distinguished in some way
um in addition to the ones that are
already bolded in the printouts
I would be open to what I I would find
it still to be difficult a day prior but
if if that's what the committee decides
I mean
um it's it's better than having to print
the whole checklist a day prior but it's
still I think it would be a tough task
for larger communities the day prior
some smaller communities you know if you
have 10 people come in it wouldn't be
that challenging but if you have a few
hundred that are requesting it could be
an issue
representative Bay
thank you Mr Vice chair thank you for
taking my question
wouldn't you say that if you uh or
tasked with uh watching the ballots as
they go in the machine
that it would be easy to tell that the
ballot was from an absentee ballot
because they would have been folded
yes I I believe it would be rather easy
to see
um an absentee ballot going into the
machine over uh an election day ballot
that was received from the ballot clerks
that day thank you
we're coming back we're swinging back
around uh representative Hamlet
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um so
um I forget what my question was
um
it's it's either a law or a rule it's in
the procedure manual that somebody has
to be standing at the voting machine
is it possible that
in Windham or in sometimes there is not
somebody standing at the voting machine
watching carefully
I mean I would say it's possible but
it's probably not likely there's usually
um yeah that someone is assigned to to
be there to watch it and if they need a
break or something say someone has a say
it's the moderator and a voter has a
question for the moderator they would
make sure that someone else is watching
uh while they're not
all right moving down from the left all
right now we'll swing back to you
representative Brennan thank you am I
understanding your testimony correctly
that when
a voter requests an absentee ballot
their name is bolded on
the checklist
yes so it's it's relatively new
um electionnet which we enter absentee
ballots into when the checklist is
printed as long as they had requested an
absentee ballot prior to us
printing then they would be in bold
it seemed like there was a little bit of
confusion but that is already happening
that absentee voters are marked in bold
and then
sorry let me just follow up please it
has to be not to be a sticker but it has
to be a question yes if I believe that
um
and when that apps CNT voter turns in
their ballot am I understanding
correctly that the checklist is then
marked with a red ink AV to declare that
that vote has been cast yes on Election
Day so
uh two hours after the polls open with
notice the clerk and moderator can start
processing apps and T ballots and at
that time during their processing when
they get to that point they go bring the
list over to the ballot Clerk and they
can cross the name off in red and right
mark them as an AV absentee voter and at
that point in current law a resident
couldn't come in and vote in person
because they have already voted
further questions from the committee
okay seeing none thank you Mr Healy
thank you all right
um
last up for my pink cards is
um deputy secretary of state Aaron
Hennessey
oh I apologize
I'm gonna
uh it came around the wrong direction I
apologize Liz tantarelli
no worries
thank you Mr chair my name is Liz
tantarelli I'm testifying today as an
individual not for my League of Women
Voters position
and uh in all honesty I already signed
in opposed I wasn't planning to speak so
I'm not trying to vote twice but
whatever
um I I was surprised at the testimony
this bill has taken because it's not
what I saw as the issue my issue is the
changing of the time from 5 PM to noon
on the day before election day because
the legislature and its wisdom
several years ago realized that there
may be occasions such as blizzards on
Election Day in town meeting remember we
had that twice in a row two years in a
row when people will decide the day
before as I did that my little car isn't
going to make that hill on Election Day
not safely anyway and so I went in and
voted absentee at about 4 30 in the
afternoon on the day before election day
so I was reading this bill and objecting
to it in that an absentee ballot would
not be able to be handed to me
at 4 30 in the afternoon on the day
before the blizzard when I realized I'm
not going to get here tomorrow
so that's just that line seven changing
it from 5 PM to noon and if I'm
misreading that and it doesn't change
that then I apologize for my
misunderstanding but it seems to say the
clerk shall send absentee ballots and
send I'm taking in the broadest sense
not bringing to them not bringing to the
post office but delivering to the voter
the clerk shall send absentee ballots in
response to verified absentee ballot
requests until noon on the day before
the election day and that was not the
intent of that bill that this
legislature so wisely passed several
years ago
so I'll leave the rest of the argument
to the other people who have testified
but I would like to see that time
changed back to the 5 PM that was in
that bill if there are questions about
that I'd happily answer them
represent Flame
um thank you Mr chair and Ms tantarelli
um
would you be comfortable if we made it
that they would send it by mail by noon
because or and then by hand by 5 PM or
by whenever they close I I suppose I'd
be comfortable if you change the word
sin to deliver
because deliver could be by hand at the
at the clerk's office which is what I
did draw that one year
um
the post office is an issue you know
trying to to mail something at 5 PM but
deliver allows for the uh the
recognition in the first several lines
of this bill which I believe is not a
change of text that delivery can be done
in a number of ways by a number of
elected officials
further questions from the committee
representative Weir so I I think the
sponsor when talking about this portion
was talking very specifically about
the
uh
sending by mail and so do you see any
problems with the as representative Lane
mentioned sending by mail and or
delivering by hand you know and having
distinct times for the two to
you accommodate the closure of post
offices
as well as you know
Town Halls that might be open for an
extended period of time to accommodate
walk-ins who are requesting absentee
ballots such as you Illustrated yourself
well I I think something has to be
clarified here frankly anybody who
trusts my mail but my post office to
deliver something that's dropped off at
noon by the next day is naive
this is not going to happen so that's
why I think the notion of deliver
allows for the town clerk to say the
only way this person who suddenly landed
in a hospital can possibly get this
absentee ballot as if I get the select
board member who's willing to do this to
hand deliver it
so I I don't
that's why I would just say exchange sin
to deliver and and leave it up to the
officials to figure out the way that
would actually work
further questions
saying none thank you thank you
um
we'll do um
any objections for a second
you're fine
thank you Mr chair and I really
appreciate the flexibility as the sole
co-sponsor of the bill in the room I
just wanted to talk to the very valid
concerns raised and to make it clear
that it is absolutely not the intent of
this bill to prevent a you know town
clerk from delivering ballots to
somebody who walks in this is strictly
about the concern that if you try to
mail something at 5 PM through the U.S
Postal Service it won't make it I
actually asked the primary sponsor why
is she comfortable with even 12 because
Gardner is delivering mail you know one
day after the other is kind of difficult
and by the way if you are at home to
receive the mail how you are you gonna
not be there to be able to vote so you
know this is absolutely and I was told
specifically that this language just
makes it clear that your obligation to
mail the ballots ends at 12s you can
still mail the ballots after 12 if you
feel that you know the Postal Service
you know will get it done and there is
absolutely zero intent to remove the
ability of anybody to walk in for as
long as the town clerk is open and vote
in person
that you know if clarifying language is
needed I'll be happy to you know
try to work with the OLS or leave it to
the committee to provide the clarifying
language but there is zero intent you
know to create that type of situation
and I would oppose those types of laws
as fiercely as I can I mean seriously
thank you
okay
next up uh deputy secretary Aaron
Hennessey
good morning everyone nice to see you
all again Aaron Hennessey deputy
secretary of state I just wanted to
give some clarification on some of the
points that were raised also probably
just repeat a lot of things that
unfortunately
um unfortunately repeat but some of the
things that other people have said
um the first section the 12 pm change
there would need to be a clarification
made an amendment made to this because
the way it is written it would be all
delivery of balance and our office is
okay with the time of the mailing of 12
pm being changed but we would oppose any
legislation that restricts somebody from
coming in until 5 PM to get a absentee
ballot
um
the and again that that would need to be
clarified via an amendment
um the intent is not clear and it would
change change the 5 PM to 12 p.m
currently
um
the the checklist if you if you look on
lines 20 and 21 and the posting of the
checklist by the supervisors
um there's a few things with this on 21
it says not sooner than 12 pm
so if for those of you legislators that
have been around for a while the devil's
always in the details and how you write
something in shall or may but not sooner
than is much different than the current
language if not later then and not
sooner than means that somebody could
post it possibly after the election
um
so that would mean to need to be
clarified but we're also opposed to the
the 12 p.m time and for for a few
different reasons
um
um we're we are in favor of posting the
checklist as soon it is corrected by the
supervisors the checklist so there's
um the current laws the fourth Tuesday
or sorry I haven't had it memorized yet
soon enough hopefully I'll be like Dave
Scanlon and have all this information
just flowing out of my head but
um and then they have once it's
corrected six to 13 days before the
election it's it's reposted
um the the form of the checklist that's
posted is not does not have absentee
voters bolded
um one of the I think one of the
committee members and somebody else who
testified said that this would be an
issue for privacy rights for for
individuals
um
I know when I go on vacation I never
Post online that I'm on vacation it's
for reasons why I don't want somebody to
know that I'm not home so they can
easily go and rob my house but that that
would be the same concern for voters
some of them who request an absentee
ballot is because they're not going to
be home at the time of the election and
this would just notify the entire public
that
um that they're not home so the current
checklist that's um posted does not have
absentee voters bolded and if you know
if you've ever requested a a checklist
from the supervisors uh sorry Secretary
of State for absentee voters only
candidates and parties and political
committees can request an absentee voter
some a list of absentee voters who've
requested so that information before an
election is not public information about
absentee voters
um so we would be opposed to the Bolding
on the checklist prior to an election
just for security information
um
the the next piece in section three
um and I believe many people spoke to
this was that someone may believe that
they're going to be absent prior to the
election but on the day of the election
their work schedule changes or their
vacation plans change and they want to
follow the letter of the law and they
um want to come in and vote in person
before their absentee ballot is
processed and the way the verbiage of is
currently written this would not allow
somebody to do that so they would kind
of have to break current law and not
vote in person even though they're not
going to be absent and just the Optics
of that is not great when you realize
your neighbor voted via absentee ballot
and you saw them in Shaw's that's not
it's not a great look for somebody so
some people when their chip plans change
do want to vote in person in the way
this is written currently wouldn't allow
that
um
I think that's all I have fair enough
questions from the committee
wow okay thanks you
um not surprising are there anyone else
who wishes to speak on House Bill 244 I
don't know why I'm gonna do that I'm
sorry sorry
all right uh can you grab the blue sheet
for me I'm gonna close I actually need
to read the blue sheet first before I
close the hearing
all right okay
um well we gotta take off that one gotta
take off that one
okay so there were
two people signed in that didn't speak
they were both signed in against it with
that I will close the public hearing on
HB 244 and I will immediately open the
uh here uh the hearing on House Bill 316
relative to meetings of the supervisor
the checklist representative Leon you're
the prime sponsor of the Bill thank you
welcome to election law um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you members of the
committee House Bill 316 is probably the
most extreme solution to a problem that
I've identified two years ago we passed
a bill that creates more categories of
reasons and ways to notify the
supervisors of the checklist of people
who may have moved from town and
therefore are subject to 30-day notices
it's come to my attention that in some
communities the supervisors of the
checklist are only meeting at the
required meetings immediately before the
elections and they're not meeting sooner
in order to deal with potential 30-day
notices
by requiring them to meet every 45 days
it would give an opportunity to clear
out those notices that would be the
shortest possible time because if you're
going to mail a 30-day notice and then
receive it you couldn't do it any
shorter than that
um I definitely understand that if we're
to require some frequency of meetings
those should be waived if there's no
notifications to be made and it should
be maybe 60 or 90 days but that's
something that I would leave to the
committee and their input there is
another potential solution too we may
want to put a limitation on how long
supervisors of the chocolate checklist
have to act upon a reason to notify an
individual that they are to be removed
there potentially to be removed from the
checklist we could say that or you could
choose to say that within 90 days a
30-day notice would need to be sent or
it could be done by these meetings I'm
open to either approach but I do want to
make sure that the this ongoing
maintenance does happen in a timely
manner that people are removed removed
appropriately and that also we don't
accidentally remove people just before
the election because they missed their
mail I think that there should be more
opportunities for this and it should be
dealt with on an ongoing basis so that's
the Genesis of the bill and I am open to
questions and better solutions to this
problem questions from the committee
okay well that oh episode of Lane
thank you um you mentioned uh not doing
it a certain like not doing it before a
certain time and I I guess before the
election and I might question you with
what would that recommendation be so
that people don't show up at the poll
and be told that I'm sorry you're no
longer registered
um thank you for the question
um I believe that the super the
checklist is essentially locked a
certain time before the election it's
just I believe just bullet for the
filing deadline and so statutorily the
supervisors need to meet a certain
amount of time before that in order to
process these requests what I'm asking
is for there to be a mechanism for
supervisors to be required to meet more
frequently if if they do have notices to
process or to have a required meeting
that could be waived if there were no
outstanding requests okay thank you for
the question representative weary so so
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you for
your testimony uh so with the timing of
the various you know local elections or
city elections and
um
I'm just I'm just sort of wondering
about uh how that all gets timed out so
as not to preclude anybody from being
removed from a list prior to you know on
an ongoing election cycle in for towns
in March and cities you know a few
months later and and then primaries and
then
uh you know those sorts of things
obviously ongoing maintenance needs to
be made but do you have any
recommendations along those lines
um thank you for the question right now
they do meet just before those election
events but those are the only times that
they're required by law to meet if you
have a large stack of say 200 requests
to send out you may or may not have the
time to to deal with all of those in
that time frame I know in Dairy at the
10-year
checklist maintenance there have been so
many that they handle those in processes
so those are the ones that happen every
decade and right after the census you go
through and anybody who hasn't voted in
four years receives one of these notices
um
because the volume is so high they need
to meet more frequently in order to
process it in a reasonable way if you
have a town where there are a lot of
these potential notices you may have
several hundred and if you're trying to
deal with those while dealing with all
of the other routine checklist
maintenance at one meeting that's a huge
burden and having a way to spread this
out where the supervisors would need to
meet more frequently if they did have
pending requests would help smooth that
curve and smooth their workload so that
they could meet before that handle these
requests and then deal with the very
important maintenance that happens just
before the primaries and the town
elections in the general
for the person it's represent Meerhead
thank you Mr chair
how often are supervisors required to
meet now thank you for the question
right now they're required to meet one
or two times before each of the times
that the checklist closes I should have
brought that specific language but it's
only immediately before elections before
this checklist is closed
follow-up follow
you're proposing that they meet twice a
quarter about eight times a year is that
correct
um that is what the language is that is
the most frequently that I think anybody
could rationally expect them to meet for
30-day notices I fully expect that if we
go with periodic meetings that it would
be longer than 45 days but I know it's
always harder to Shorter a Time shorten
a time frame so I thought it best to
start with the shortest possible and so
the highest frequency and then find
where that reasonable time frame is
are you aware whether whether
supervisors of the checklists are
compensated
um thank you I believe they're better
compensated than we are
it's a bar solo you could trip over it
okay
you have further questions
I representative Hamlet
oops
thank you for taking my question
um
I think
this bill is better better than the I
think this is a great bill and I I
because in Portsmouth the supervisors of
the checklist meet every month
and they re you know clean up the
checklist every month so
um and I was surprised to recently find
out that and sometimes they don't meet
everyone's so it seems like the year 6
27 a is is better
than uh just 6 27. can can we just amend
the wording uh in 65427 instead of
adding another section
um so I I my first question is is the
627 the one that requires them to meet
just before every election yes
um thank you I think it should be in
addition to that because if you were to
schedule the meetings and then be 44
days before the best time to update the
checklist for the election you could
lose some options there too those
meetings my intention is that these
meetings here would also satisfy that
requirement and that it wouldn't be an
addition to it wouldn't be on top of it
it would just simply add to it so that
throughout the year the supervisors were
meeting and I'd just like to say that
it's fantastic that the supervisors in
Portsmouth meet monthly thank you
further questions from the committee
okay seeing nothing representative Leon
only one pink card for this
um uh Dan Healy
Mr Healy you are what is between us and
lunch so be wary I'll be quick so Dan
Haley uh representing New Hampshire City
and town clerks Association uh so we do
support this bill
um representative Leon spoke to a little
bit we would just like the change to be
to 60 days
um and it's say like supervisors must
meet
um at minimum within six days because
their statutory meeting requirements
already in place so if you have a
statutory requirement to meet we want to
be want to be on a you know the timer
should start again after that meeting so
we're recommending 60 days or a set
amount of days per year say six or ten
or whatever it is because of the
statutory requirements already in place
to meet on certain days so you wouldn't
want to say like every 45 days they need
to meet because they're meeting anyway
so our only recommendation would be the
60 days instead of 40 five but we do
support it
questions from the committee look at
that see when you threaten lunch no one
wants to ask questions all right thank
you uh representative can you grab us
the blue sheet please
all right
okay uh there were two people three
people signed in two against one four
um when with that I will close the here
the public hearing on House Bill 316. uh
we will reconvene
um at one o'clock for HP 415 uh enjoy a
long lunch
foreign
okay thank you oh this is very loud here
I'll back up
thank you committee for your time and
listening to hb415 I'm here to introduce
this bill on behalf of the sponsor
representative panic
the Secretary of State commissioned the
committee for voter confidence and
testimony revealed that half of those
who came forward had concerns about New
Hampshire's elections we need to take
steps to improve this confidence level
and one very important way of doing this
is by creating election transparency
we have many people in New Hampshire who
are concerned about our voting machines
with the results of the Wyndham audit
demonstrating issues that rendered
incorrect results many have become
election Skeptics and they have no way
to lessen their concerns as voters
cannot see the ballots that make up
their elections why is this there are no
federal laws that prohibit making
ballots public information
federal law leaves this up to the states
to decide so why does the New Hampshire
why does New Hampshire prevent access to
ballots from 91a requests through
research and Records requests it appears
that legislation
is to exclude ballots and it came off
after recount results in the Hampstead
elections were overturned when a citizen
requested to see the ballots in the late
80s
this was described in a public
selectman's hearing and testimony during
the Wyndham audit
in 2003 a superior court judge ruled
ballots were in fact part of 91a
so a request was made by then deputy
secretary of state Scanlon and Bud Fitch
assistant AG
to add an amendment to HB 627 a memo
authored by the pair requesting the
following add a new section to hb627
exempting ballots used for elections
from RSA 91a this proposed amendment is
prompted by a recent superior court
order declaring that the ballots cast in
an election are not exempt from the
right to no law and requiring a town to
provide a person making a 91a request
demand to have access to all the ballots
preserved from a recent town meeting
the Integrity of ballots and the
finality of election results requires
that there be limited and highly
controlled access to the ballots used
for elections
the existing recount and recount appeal
Provisions provide adequate access to
ballots under
circumstances
the logic behind the request is
unfortunately flawed every citizen in
New Hampshire has the right to election
transparency not just candidates who are
the only eligible parties to request a
recount
and for their race only after this
provision was made law of New Hampshire
citizens lost their ability to validate
election results making it impossible to
tie reported results to votes cast
citizens have no ability to ensure the
reported election results are in fact
the will of the people without using
ballots
this erodes voter confidence and worse
preventing access to ballots adds fuel
to the fire that they're being withheld
be because of the agenda not because
that this is good policy
concerns in the past have been raised
that public ballot access violates voter
privacy however all recounts make
visible
every ballot and privacy has never been
an issue
other concerns about public ballot
access centered on voters selling or
being coerced to use their ballot and
marketing it for future confirmation
however technology would allow a simple
photo to confirm a voter's ballot
so no markings would be needed
we recognize public access to ballots
will need to be organized and balanced
with the workloads of towns but we owe
it to our voters to make this happen
Public Access is done in other states
today and most certainly can be done
here in New Hampshire Vermont uses the
identical voting machines and ballots as
New Hampshire they make their ballots
available to the public this is a great
source of voter confidence for Vermont
Arizona just passed bipartisan
legislation to make all ballot images
available to the public by passing HB
2560.
they recognize that their citizens
deserve to have the confidence in the
election results and one of the most
important ways to do this is to make the
results Audible
through publicly available ballot images
so we are asking this committee to
restore access to ballots as part of the
public record for New Hampshire citizens
just like the bipartisan efforts just
announced in Arizona
this bill
for We the People for everyone to be
able to verify election results for
themselves
thank you for listening
thank you will you take questions
um I
okay I'm just introducing it so if
there's anybody here that is also
supporting you I'll let them yeah thank
you thank you
again representative Reed
thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members of the election law
committee for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent rockinghamton
that is Newmark in new fields and I'm
coming before you today I am not a
co-sponsor I don't think I knew that
this was getting filed but I filed this
bill in various forms uh I believe 2018
the second year I was in office again in
2019 in my second term and in my third
term I asked the Republican to file it
for me thinking maybe someone across the
aisle might have more luck than me
um so for the record the historically we
always had ballots available as 91a
public documents as a matter of
transparency it is in our state
constitution that elections shall be
counted and I'm sure you heard earlier
tabulated may be different than counted
or may not be
um but the idea I think the spirit of
that part of the Constitution is that
everything has to be done in public and
certainly that is the Constitution says
that we have to do these things in
public in the open
um the history and I won't speak I think
the previous testimony spoke a little
bit to the history of why
um it was removed from 91a but the
actual mechanism by which it was removed
from 91a I find suspect it was put into
a bill it was a non-germane amendment in
the Senate side in a bill and that
non-germaine amendment that removed
ballots is 91a documents uh did not have
a hearing so I find that problematic on
its face but here we are today without
ballots being 91a
um I so as I said I've I've Prime
sponsored this and assisted in this
being Prime sponsored three times prior
all of which were prior or I think all
of which at least two of which were
prior to the 2020 election and I really
feel strongly that if we had had this in
place we may have at least as a state
experience less divisiveness during the
2020 election because my Approach has
always been since way before it became a
you know a major topic of national
discourse that
sunlight is the best disinfectant if you
that that conspiracy theories cannot
grow in complete and pure transparency
so while I may not believe that there's
any you know
bad things afoot with how ballots are
counted it doesn't matter what I believe
what matters is what other people have
informed have information for and if we
are completely transparent about it then
we can't have you just don't have an
environment where conspiracy theories
can take off and as as a prime sponsor
of this in 2018 and 2019 I'm on record
with that position long before any of
those conversations got started
so for the record my bills and prior had
some slightly different language I'd
like to just tell you really briefly
about it in case for whatever reason the
committee sees fit to try to amend this
particular one my bill and this is a
little bit outside the the realm of just
this bill but I allowed moderators to do
public audits of machines random audits
of a particular race and particular
machine I allowed the townspeople to buy
petition before the election ask for a
random audit of a machine just to verify
that the machines are producing reliable
results and I also had in my previous
iterations of this bill very specific
language exempting ballots that had
identifiable markings and ballots that
for example absentee ballots look
different so if you had a district where
maybe you only had two people vote
absentee those would be Exempted because
it would be too narrow of a field of
people you could potentially narrow it
down to who had what ballot so so
um if the committee is interested in
that language I'm happy to provide it to
you if you want if you see fit that the
the incentive of the bill is good but
you want to get into the Weeds on
language
the only argument that I ever heard
against this that I can recall and the
many times that I had presented it
um was that there was a bit of concern
around the concept of buying a vote so
the idea that someone could say that
I'll accept money in order to vote a
certain way then they vote a certain way
that's 91a now it's completely
accessible to the public and then I
could go and check I found this argument
absolutely but to be frank quite
ridiculous so first of all you can take
a picture of your ballot as we know and
that would suffice as proof of your vote
if you were to be a bad actor and sell
your vote but if you were a bad actor
and tried to buy a vote I would strongly
warn against the idea of going and
requesting a 91a record on those ballots
to then basically admit that you have
bought a vote it would be an impractical
way to verify that illegally bought vote
and a very transparent way of of showing
that you are probably not a great actor
but as I said in my previous bills I did
exempt personally identifying
marked ballots from that bill and with
that I'm happy to attempt to answer any
questions
thank you we have any questions
representative weary
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Reed for your testimony
um
just curious if your previous bills
addressed the concept of ballot images
versus the counting of ballots
no I don't I don't so what you mean like
the actual Counseling of ballots versus
the access to the image so it's just the
image and again my language also
included
um guidelines around how that would be
available so for example like we do with
recounts
um uh you can have like screens and then
there's a person in the other room
showing you the ballot over a screen and
then you can say okay next Ballot or
look at this part or what have you so it
doesn't require the person being in
person with the ballot or physically
touching the ballot and you can also if
once we had the technology have the
valid images available
well follow up Mr chair
so so
you're not asked this doesn't make a
provision necessarily for a recount per
se but just access to ballot images so
that people can go in and verify it
right without without the mechanisms of
a recount correct exactly precisely so
we don't have machines currently that
automatically create valid images
although I'm sure that whatever machine
we end up with probably will have that
ability but this like any other 91a
request this simply allows us to be
transparent so that anyone could see oh
yeah it really was 300 votes that voted
for this candidate for example so it's
just the ability to see the actual
ballots which I think is completely in
keeping with the spirit of the
Constitution that says that we have to
do this in public
thank you
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
in your previous bills and in this bill
is there a time frame by which someone
would be able to make this request or a
time limit
there's there's not and uh to the extent
that there is a time limit for the
government to respond to a 91a request I
understand that is also a topic that's
being legislated currently but um that
it's it's a pretty squishy but the
government is expected to respond to 91a
requests in a timely manner follow it
please follow up thank you so
under 91a someone can request records
from
quite a long time ago so
I'm trying to understand if this bill
would allow someone to make a 91a
request for ballots from an election
10 years ago 15 years ago 20 years ago
so there's yes there's no limit on 91a
having said that 91a and the point of
91a is that the government provides the
records that it has to the extent we
don't have those records the government
is not beholden to provide them so I
could make a 91a request for maybe the
year of 1800 for what a particular town
did in the year 1800 certainly that town
probably doesn't have those records
anymore and that's fine
and we do dispose of ballots after a
certain period in this state thank you
moving forward though it would be
consistent and then once we have the
technology we would have those images in
perpetuity
thank you
um
so to get to images at least when I read
the bill it doesn't talk about images it
talks about the actual balance although
in the heading it talks about
that I mean the analysis images of
ballots so is this to get the actual
balance or is this to get the images of
the ballots I believe the inconsistency
in wording here is because of the
development of technology so up until
recently having access to about the
ballots would be simply access to see
the ballots not to lay hold on of them
obviously but to see them so the idea of
the image now we have digital technology
that can allow us to do that digitally
and that's the same as if you were to do
a 91a for your town whatever kind of
meeting you had they would provide you
in in today's world they would provide
you a digital record of those things
that you're requesting not the actual
physical record okay so to clarify
providing I'm sorry
to clarify uh
if a 918
is requested providing the images of
those ballots would be deemed sufficient
that's how I understand all of 91a to
work at this point if for whatever
reason this committee decided that that
was not clear enough for your liking in
this particular bill I think it would be
wise to amend it to make sure that we
are kind of like a future proofing so
we're clear that images count as a
delivery of 91a thank you
any other questions
representative Bay
thank you thank you for taking my
question so
um again uh with regard to the statement
of to the extent that ballots or images
are available they should be made
available uh is there a current law on
uh for how long
um whoever's the responsible party is
for how long they are supposed to keep
those images or videos
so I believe it this committee would
know better than me I believe the town
keeps it you say three okay I thought it
was two for whatever reason but so the
town keeps it for the physical ballots
for three years we as far as I know and
again this committee would have more
expertise in this field than I do as far
as I know we don't have language in
terms of keeping the image of the ballot
because we don't currently automatically
make images of ballots so I would
suggest that you all address that issue
um because again it's a it's a matter of
future proofing certainly whatever next
generation of machines are coming our
way will likely have the ability to make
those automatic images of the ballots
and that would be far more efficient and
long-term than keeping a warehouse of
physical ballots
thank you you have no follow-up any
other questions
representative weary
so just I think there's a federal
requirement for 21 22 months something
like that for a general election so I
think
uh maybe maybe there ought to be some
Provisions about you know use as you
said you indicated that
91a applies to the records that are
maintained and and maybe we need to make
record-keeping Provisions accordingly
for for ballot images
uh so the question is do you think we
should keep record keep you know
Institute record-keeping requirements
for valid images I I do so that's what I
I was hoping to address in the previous
question but obviously since our
technology has developed it was in the
past it was Impractical to tell towns or
the Secretary of State to keep all the
ballots forever and ever and ever
because eventually your Warehouse is
just too big but
um now that we have digital images it
would be a very easy thing to do and
easy to make available to the public so
I would suggest again if you would like
to amend this there are other things in
terms of restricting certain ballots
that are identifiable but also the idea
of addressing the difference between yes
the town and in the 22-month figure may
be why I had it in my head that was two
years but uh addressing yes the towns
have to keep it for three years
physically but the images the digital
images shall be kept in perpetuity or
something like that
and it may be the the purview of the
Secretary of State to keep that database
rather than the towns
representative wood per question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh I don't know if this is
appropriate but can you tell me why the
bill didn't pass before
as I so the Secretary of State
um who I and this is the previous
Secretary of State but I believe the
current Secretary of State was acting in
his stead in that committee room that
day as I recall
um and the argument was what about
buying votes and that was the only
argument that I remember
um but we didn't seem to have a problem
with buying votes beforehand and
certainly today with cell phones you
could easily buy a vote and more
secretly buy a vote just by having a
picture of that vote I'm certainly not
advocating anyone buy or sell their
votes but it this allowing it to be 91a
addresses a huge transparency issue that
we have and it doesn't increase any
danger of the selling and buying of
votes at all
follow-up follow-up please
um so the buying of votes was what came
out because I I couldn't find follow
your argument too well and you said it
was confusing so I'm sorry no no I
haven't I've never been to be confusing
the so how can you just repeat that one
more time to buy in a vote so since that
was a critical piece because I don't get
it thank you so in my previous
iterations of the bill I made the
arguments that I made before you today
about transparency and doing things in
the public and this being the the
underlying like point of democracy or
underlying basis of democracies that we
all understand what's going on and the
Secretary of State the deputy secretary
of state then uh argued when against the
bills saying he is concerned that if we
return it to 91a this may assist people
in the buying and selling of votes
illegally the argument is that if those
images of those ballots or the ballots
themselves are available to the public
then I as a bad actor having bought your
vote can go make a 91a request check and
see and you may have marked your ballot
in identical diet identifiable way for
example you told me ahead of time that
you were going to write Donald duck in
for a write-in for a particular race
then I find that particular ballot I
look and then you voted for the
candidate I want and then I pay you my
argument is a if you're buying someone's
vote you probably shouldn't make a
public record of the fact that you then
went and checked to see and make sure
that the vote you bought was was correct
and then B there's a much more simple
way of doing that which is simply the
person whose vote you are buying takes a
photograph of their ballot with their
camera so I do not think that making
this public record increases the
likelihood of anyone buying or selling
votes it may increase the likelihood of
catching people who buy votes but but it
does address a major transparency issue
that we have
any other questions
this is with regard to your comment
about keeping the images in perpetuity
I'm just curious do you believe that the
cloud is infinite
no
so every server exists somewhere and to
the extent servers exist somewhere they
are susceptible to being damaged broken
what have you so there are flaws but
that's why we have redundancy so you
know if you ever have tried to remove
like um
a negative article or a image or a post
or something from the internet
it's hard to get rid of it it's hard to
get take something completely off of the
internet because there's so many copies
that get made of that information so
using that same premise
um the cloud while Eddie one particular
server is vulnerable when you have
multiple copies you have so much
redundancy that in effect you can keep
things in perpetuity
okay thank you I the only thank you
representative thank you the only other
card I have is for
deputy secretary Aaron herrenson
just a minute
I have one for you sir for 460 but not
for this one
uh Dan Healy
foreign
good afternoon members of the committee
Dan Healy representing New Hampshire
City and town clerks Association and we
oppose this bill there's too many
concerns that we have with this bill the
way it's currently written at the end of
the night on an election we have to seal
the boxes with red security tape we have
to have a town clerk and moderator and
sign the seal along with Selectmen and
we place that on the box
the current law
only a court order you can then go back
and open that box so this doesn't
address that
so we have some concerns within
retrieving the ballots and bringing them
out for our 91a request in the larger
communities I have probably 50 60 ballot
boxes from the general election
um
in a resident could come in there's no
timeline on this a resident could come
in or any any citizen can come in any
time and request to see all these
ballots there's no procedure for the
viewing
um there's no guidelines on how to do
this
um for as far as transparency goes to
and the communities that I've worked
we've asked people that have concerns
about elections to work the elections
they can see the process they can see
the ballots at recounts you're seeing
the ballots you're seeing what was
marked
so just overall we just have a lot of
concerns with this this bill and I'd be
open to any questions
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Healy
um
for
ballot images you have the same
objections that you have with the
current ballot process so I agree that
there are I think huge difficulties with
uh the language here at perhaps
instituting a a recount process
inadvertently but if there were ballot
images if the machine through capturing
those images and then having those made
available to the public
with the clerk's Association have any
objections with that we didn't
specifically um discuss that I know the
high image scanners are rather expensive
I don't know if every Community would be
able to afford those and then what's the
process after the ballots are sealed to
then run them through the scanner so
there's not much that's really laid out
for the procedure so even if we were to
scan the images how would that how would
we then do that so then after the
election say a week or two later would
we then be allowed to open the boxes up
and run them through the scanner and
then you know what about the towns that
may not be able to afford I think it
might be five thousand dollars for a
scan a
fast scanner I'm not quite sure on the
cost on that but I know they're rather
expensive
representative Brennan thank you and
thank you for taking my
tweaking about the financial impact of
municipalities
given that this bill does not outline a
procedure and we're talking about
digital scanning would you say there is
in a heavy burden for municipalities and
town employees If This Were to be
implemented
uh yeah I would say so if if this bill
passes the way it is and someone could
come in and request to see all our
ballots I believe in Nashua for the
general election we had I want to say 33
000 ballots cast
um and there's you know they're in a
secure location to then bring those uh
to City Hall and to have them you know I
don't know I don't know how you would do
it really how I'd get 33 000 ballots
there and uh be able to have someone
view them
any other questions
okay thank you thanks
okay representative popovichi Moa
how was I
thank you very much Mr chairman you must
have taken uh lessons from
representative very earlier right
um I I do want to apologize by the way
for forgetting to turn in my pin card
you are correct I submitted 144.60 I
thought I submitted one for this but I
recall I only turned it on so
I want to be very quick but since I
inadvertently ended up at the tail end
of this I would rather instead of
telling you what I was gonna tell you if
I was allowed to speak first address a
couple of the things that may be concern
the committee
the only thing that I'll say that I was
going to say first is that this is
purely transparency bill you know the
intent is to to just help people gain
confidence in the way the government
works by requiring the government to be
transparent and you all understand how
critical elections are and Trust in the
elections are and I don't need to you
know sell you on that point
just a couple of things first we had
this in the past this is not a
unforeseen situation ballots have been
produced in response to 91a requests and
nothing terrible happened if anything at
least in one case
that process resulted in an error that
would have changed the results being
caught and found in time but the intent
of this bill is not to do that
I think that the healthy way to look at
the election process is to understand
that whatever results are certified by
the Secretary of State are final that it
is the best effort the intent of this is
to not reopen that Pandora's Box is just
to allow people after the fact
to take a look at uh you know how the
sausage was made for the lack of a
better term
and yes not every restaurant is happy
with people looking in their kitchen but
good restaurants are
I know that there is concern that people
you know
are worried about
people taking too close of a look but I
would urge you to consider the
importance of trust and the ability of
people to check the work
and um
in regards to the procedure that is
needed
representative read was kind enough to
remind me that her previous build
language had procedures
and frankly it has been my experience
that you know if one tries to keep a
bill simple like this one is this one
literally removes a paragraph and adds a
line people are gonna say oh my God you
don't have procedure well I just had
another bill which had a lot of
procedure eviscerated because the
procedure was present and I shouldn't
tell the Departments how to do their job
if the Departments would like to have
procedure I'm sure the legislature is
happy to provide it and this you know
committee has all the knowledge they
need and again they have previous bills
where they can address that if that's
what holding this bill back my
philosophy on this bill is that I
absolutely trust the people who are
already handling 91a requests to handle
requests for ballots in the same way
they handle any other 91a request we
don't give people the original contract
we give them a copy of it and by the way
in regards to cost we have the ability
to charge them a reasonable cost per
copy because there is a cost in you know
the materials and everything so
you know if you are a small town you
don't need to buy a high speed scanner
you can share one with 15 other towns
and use it when it's needed and I'm sure
there will be an enterprising soul that
will buy a truck and buy a scanner and
go around helping towns that don't have
their own scanners
I believe that we have a duty
to be open to our people I think that
this bill is very simple and very
straightforward
and um
I believe that it is a bill that the
committee should support actually out of
all the bills that I'm presenting and
God knows I'm coming here for 460 and
I'm excluding that one from this
statement
I think this is the one that honestly
should be the most bipartisan everybody
in this room I would hope understand the
importance of the transparencies this is
not a Republican or a Democrat point of
view it's simply a we are accountable to
the people that we serve and that
includes showing them you know the
public records that are generated I
really appreciate your patience thank
you thank you any questions
with that thank you and
thank you thank you and now call on
deputy secretary Aaron Herron Hennessey
thank you Mr chair good afternoon
everyone Aaron Hennessey deputy
secretary of state we are opposed to
this bill as written
um
a little information
um just quickly
um the read the sorry I can't see all of
you
um so for federal elections ballots have
to be
um election materials have to be kept
for 22 months and for local elections
it's 60 days but that that's if there's
no pending litigation going on so just
uh I know there was a lot of talk about
what the timelines are
um
so as I said we are opposed to this
legislation uh currently if you want to
open
um election materials and I say election
materials because this just does not
relate to the nice flat ballots it
relates to the wrinkled up outer
envelopes the affidavit envelopes the
um
the absentee ballot applications and all
of the other materials and and the
folded ballots the anything that you if
you've been to a recount that you've
seen that we go through at a recount
that's all of the election materials
that this relates to so
um
currently as some of the other speakers
noted the these boxes can only be opened
at a recount by a court order or if if
um accidentally someone election night
put their return of votes form sealed it
up into a box which occasionally does
happen then there is a process where the
state has to come and that box is open
in front of the state this legislation
doesn't account for any of that so our
reading of it is that if
um someone locally requests for a state
election material box to be opened and
to access those materials that we would
have to go around to every locality and
observe that opening of the materials so
if you were to pass that just take that
into consideration
one other thing to consider is that
approximately half of our towns in New
Hampshire do not have ballot counting
devices the wording the language in this
bill also I'm not considering any
proposed amendments that were spoken of
does not talk about scanned images it if
the reading of it is that ballot
election materials so it's full access
to all of the pieces of paper
so a lot of towns in New Hampshire if a
ballot if the ballot law commission does
approve a new accounting device which I
anticipate they do those new devices can
scan and store those images
but half the towns in New Hampshire
currently don't have a ballot counting
device and they probably won't have the
new one either so they won't have those
images scanned and again the pallet
counting devices that will be approved
in the future are not going to be
scanning envelopes affidavits and other
election materials so there's there's
not going to be all of that information
in the cloud someplace
um
the
the individual's right to a private
ballot
um we we take that
um if you when you walk into a polling
location and you go and you see you can
walk into a ballot Booth or use one of
the screens there's a reason why we have
that because in New Hampshire we want to
protect your right to or your private
ballot
um and in in the cases where
um images are maybe scanned or just
shared in general somebody has access to
the papers we feel that that imp that
privacy may be violated especially if
there's somebody
has a disability and uses the um the
machine to help them vote those ballots
look a little different if somebody's
used to yokava ballot and in some
instances some people actually sign
their name to their ballot so those
individuals would lose that right to a
private ballot
um
there was a lot of talk about
um the um
the why this 91a was removed initially
and that has to do with um possible
possible buying of ballots we do still
have that concern
um there are very
um schemey people out there you know you
read about
um abuses happening all the time Elder
abuses Financial related but there's
um very talented folks out there who
could come up with some sort of scheme
to buy ballots and buy your vote
um say if if I know if I want you to
vote for this person you're going to
have to put on the county commissioner
line Aaron Hennessey and there'd be some
sort of scheme where they'd be able to
do that and then check and make sure
you've done that
um this used to happen
um and that's why in the 1800s
um the United States got away from that
option and moved to secret ballots so
that
um people weren't or at least instances
of that were reduced so that's one of
our concern another concern is that
there is no FN on this note and I know
since I used to be on the finance
committee in both the house and the
Senate that um you're not supposed to
look at the fiscal impact because you're
a policy committee but I just want to
say that this bill did not come to our
office for a fiscal note and if it did
it would be
um it would be very it would be a high
dollar amount and I can imagine that if
it went to the municipal Association I
don't think they've testified on this
that they would also have a very a big
fiscal concern whether it be to buying a
scanner or a person's time and the the
biggest thing is the time so right now
ballots are are not accessible because
of 91a but ballot boxes are
and people do come to our office and ask
to see our logs to measure the boxes to
count the boxes to look at the seals and
that's a very time consuming process and
we are in favor of that process because
we want to make sure that
um we're very transparent and open about
our elections and we follow the laws as
they're written but I do want to say
that there would be a huge fiscal impact
for people being able to come in and
look at each of the ballot or affidavit
envelope
in addition we want to make sure that
this these are the official election
materials and if somebody has access to
the physical election materials and can
touch them
um there there could be things that
happen to those materials so
I'm happy to take questions
any questions
representative thank you Mr chairman
it was talked about in a another
person's testimony that this is done in
Vermont are you aware of it being done
in any other state I ask because Vermont
uses the same electronic ballot counting
machines that we do which at this point
doesn't have that capability so are they
using
additional equipment what do you know I
actually don't know what they do but I'm
happy to find out for you thank you
any other questions representative thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question would you also consider the
storage of ballot images to have fiscal
impact
yes
they will they will have a fiscal impact
they're
um sorry thank you for the question
um we would have to come up with a
process to store them
um at the state level to make
to scan them and store everything and
again it's election materials it's not
just the ballots I mean at the local
level there would be a fiscal impact to
them as well especially
um for for local elections
follow up follow-up
um so uh you said that currently there's
a requirement to um store the ballots
for 22 months or something like that
what would be your recommendation uh if
you would have one uh for how long the
ballot images would be stored
my understanding is that the ballot
images if we were to move to a different
ballot counting device which again I'm
sure that we will be that those would be
stored for 22 months as well
thank you
representative Bruno
uh thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
this question I just first wanted to
confirm the new devices can scan and
take images of ballots is that correct
that's correct and um follow up please
uh who's going to be paying for these
new devices the state or the town and
cities
generally the towns and cities elect
locally to use a ballot counting device
and they pay for that themselves along
with the
um Annual fees okay thank you
thank you and in terms of time I think
we end in questions and this closes the
hearing on 4 15 after representative
ankenberg gets made of blue sheet
an order
okay on the blue sheet we have
one two three four knows and one yes
and with that
turning the chair you have it now dabble
down on
4 15 and we're going to open up
484 with
chair Berry
okay
I'm gonna open up the election house
election public hearing on 484 relative
to the handling of absentee ballot
envelopes prior to election day
um
uh representative posts are you here yes
there you are representative post was my
seat mate last year see how to sit next
to me imagine how bad that was for her
um
I thoroughly enjoyed it and still do
even though you're behind me
um I think the chair and the committee
um for allowing me to testify today and
I am the prime sponsor of this bill this
is a excuse me
this is a constituent bill for my town I
am a deputy town clerk as well so House
Bill 484
is a simple Bill oh and I just wanted to
say
um that I am Lisa post from the town of
lineborough I am a representative and I
represent lineborough Mount Vernon and
New Boston
so
house pool 484 was
um uh constituent bill from My Town
Clerk and during covid we experienced
that opening the ballots the day before
which we were allowed to do during covid
gave us a quiet time to open the ballots
and make sure that the ballots the outer
envelope that the affidavit envelope was
completely signed and everything was
all right with it and then we would
highlight in our
in our book the person's name
so that the next day during election
when the moderator when we had a quiet
time if there was a quiet time
the moderator would call out
that name and we would put a line
underneath we would note the ballot
after it was opened whether it was a
Democrat or Republican and then it was
put in to the election box we are a hand
count town and there's a lot of hand
count towns in New Hampshire so this
bill would help
people who are running the election to
be able to hear the moderator
even when it's busy because they already
know what's coming things are in order
we know they're going to call they're
going to call them in order and we're
just going to go to that checkbook and
say yes now now this ballot is going
into the box
so it's it's a simple build but it helps
and it's transparent it's open to the
public
and it doesn't
um hurt anyone and it actually helps
folks who may have forgot to put in a
signature on it or their address so that
as a clerk we can call them and say if
it's the day before or two days before
um It's usually the day before that we
open it so it's the day before we can
call that person and say are you still
here today are you willing to come and
sign your Ballot or whatever they forgot
to put in so I think this is simple and
easy and effective for small towns and
I'd like to see the schematic committee
with an ought to pass
any questions questions
Hamlet thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
um I like I like the idea of being able
to open the outer envelopes before
election day and I think what during
covet I think in Portsmouth we started
the opening process on Friday or
Saturday before the election of course
there were a lot more absentee ballots
than what would you be willing to change
the date instead of the Monday prior to
a few days earlier I would absolutely
like that because then it gives if that
person was leaving the day that we are
opening them obviously we won't have
that ability to help them so I I would
definitely do that I think we picked
that date because that's what we were
given during coven that day before and I
don't know if it was a decision by our
moderator or whether it came down from
the state so yes we would be happy to do
that okay thank you
further questions
I I have a question
um
how does this not create two classes of
Voters so you've got the voters who will
receive your ballot curing protections
the Monday before the election and
you'll have the voters who are having
their absentee ballots that arrive on
Election Day they will not receive that
protection
um you said in there your intention is
to allow people to ballot cure that's
what it's called it's called ballot
caring
um how do you how are you not creating
two classes of Voters at that point and
if you move it even farther forward
you're even you're creating even more
you're loading up that second class
I I don't have an answer to that
um I
people send in their ballots and it gets
there uh by that date those people have
the ability to
um you know receive a call or be able to
change not change anything but fill in
informations that you've left for a
blank
um I I understand that your thought is
there's another class of people that
aren't
um now able to change their ballot
because it is election day but
unfortunately I mean it's the same thing
with people who are voting who don't
fill out an absentee ballot in time to
get to us that don't really get counted
so I think there is already another
class of of people that don't have that
ability to
um have that same consideration
further questions
representative Grill
uh yeah I sort of have a question
following up on representative Barry's
question and thank you for
um thank you Mr Karen thanks for taking
the question I should have started with
that
um
the um absentee ballots
um in terms of like the envelopes and
the additional materials that come with
them
um do in-person ballots cast
um require the same process as far as
completing the affidavit and the
envelope yes they do so that that
envelope goes out with
um I believe three envelopes there's an
outer envelope there's the affidavit
envelope and then there's the ballot
envelope and the ballot envelope isn't
opened at all until the day of the
election and the problems that we have
in our town is we have a very high
ceiling and when people are coming in
going through it's really noisy so
having that ability to avoid mistakes in
our checklist is really important
because the end of the night when and
especially during a presidential
election
you have different ballot clerks that
have messed up they checked another name
it's a similar name and things like that
and we spend all night trying to figure
out you know how to fix this and where
the problem is so I I do think it's a
win-win to do this
um so if a voter is asked to cure their
ballot in advance of the election day um
they wouldn't be allowed to alter any
markings on the ballot itself just the
um envelope and additional materials
that come with the absentee ballot
correct correct okay thank you I'd like
to follow that why not
why not why not well it depends what
whether we've already opened the
envelope right it it if it's ballot day
and they come in and they decide
um it's election day excuse me and they
come in and we've already opened the
ballots to put in the box that that's
said and done we can't change that we
can't take it out of The Ballot Box if
they come in early enough before we do
it then there is a possibility they can
pull that ballot back
but but it's it depends on the timing
couldn't they just come in before 8 A.M
and vote regularly That's the Law as it
is today
well we don't open till 8 A.M so was it
eight hours in noon I can't forget it I
think it's eight Ryan
any other questions
uh representative
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
the text in this bill
s about the voters
shall be announced and an opportunity
for a challenge of the ballot shall be
given
and then it also talks about identifying
in a primary if there is a if they've
pulled a Dem or a republican ballot is
there any concern about
um
privacy and the you know
secret ballot
so with the first section where the
outer envelope is being opened we're not
announcing a name we're looking to see
if all the information on the affidavit
because the affidavit is on the outside
of the envelope that they fill out and
they we open the the first envelope and
there's the affidavit envelope and
inside the Avid envelope is then their
ballot so we just look at the front is
this a valid affidavit is it signed is
it completed and and that is all we're
looking for and at that point we
highlight the names of that person on
the ballot on on the checklist excuse me
Paula yeah of course
so
why would it say the voter's name shall
be announced and and let me just clarify
that
um part of your testimony was that this
is about transparency and the public
would be able to view this and now
you're going to have people opening
these envelopes announcing voters names
um identifying that that voter has voted
absentee to the public is that something
that is standard practice and that is
standard practice for us
um I I don't know how others towns do it
but whether it be
we are you know in the middle of of the
election
we try to wait for a law and the
moderator and this is without this the
moderator announces uh the person's name
so we can check it off on the list
representative way
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so the first part is really
just about verification of the affidavit
correct
that's all it is and it it during covid
um there was and and they everybody
talks about election Integrity now this
helps election Integrity because now
these folks who would have
um their ballots may not have been
counted
um were validated to be counted
um then
now they have the opportunity to do that
so that gives you know a little more
election Integrity to our system uh that
you know we're reaching out to these
people
before
the election
further questions on the committee
uh yes representative O'Brien thank you
thank you Mr chairman
uh
has the amount of absentee ballots
remained consistent since covid or has
it changed it's it's
yeah yes it has changed during covet a
lot of people used it because they could
use it for anything so now we've gone
back to just the normal I mean uh we're
a small town and we have a great voter
turnout and people want to come out and
see their neighbors and talk and have
chili and gather so at least for us as a
community we find more people want to be
out see their neighbors especially if
there's not a lot of snow on the ground
further questions
we'll find out about snow today
all right well that's uh that I think
only have one other card
um Dan Healy oh thank you I assume
there's nobody in the question so I I
thank you oh
hi Dan Healy uh representing New
Hampshire City and town clerks
Association I'll be real brief with this
our association supports this bill uh we
would just like to see the date move
from Monday to Friday to give us a
couple days to actually process
those ballots so if it could be moved to
Friday we could start Friday we could do
it Saturday Sunday Monday give clerks
some time to to get this accomplished
I'm open to any questions
representative
um thank you um Mr Clark Mr chair
s thank you Mr Healy um
in the bill for during covid when it was
changed it talked about you had to
publicly announce when you were going to
do this so if we're going to change it
to Friday would you be okay with the
provision that you have to announce when
you're going to do it because it could
be Friday Saturday I doubt you're going
to do Sunday but or Monday so that would
be okay to do that okay thank you
representative weary
and just kind of following up on that
that those would be like reasonable
hours you know normal kind of business
hours yes
um in having it you know start Friday so
we could post that we're doing this
Saturday during you know during the day
or something along those lines where we
would have the staff to do it and people
could still come out and and see it
okay are there any other questions
I have one why not just count them there
on Election Day no you've already opened
up the ballots why not just count them
if you're pre-processing them it's gonna
be faster I want to just count them
I don't believe with current law we can
until election day
all right any other questions
thank you thank you uh next up is Luis
Spencer
welcome hi thank you for taking my last
minute request to speak
um I'm Louise Spencer I'm from Concord
I'm with the Kent Street Coalition which
is an all volunteer Grassroots advocacy
organization today I'm speaking on my
own behalf I obviously had not planned
to speak but hearing the sponsor on this
bill
and having observed pre-processing
um
in in several different towns I
um I really do underscore and the value
of having that ability to do that
my concern about this bill was that it
was uh so late on Monday that it it
would not necessarily give a lot of time
to the um
to do the curing of the ballots and also
that it you know clerks are very busy
getting ready
um for the election the next day
um so the Monday dates seemed
problematic but to the extent that the
date as several have mentioned here
would be moved even to Friday
I would fully support this bill I will
say that having participated in
observing this process and seeing
um clerks and other election officials
reaching out to voters they are so
grateful uh you know if they just forgot
to sign the affidavit they're so
grateful for that opportunity to fix
that and this is both Republicans and
Democrats it's not a this is a very
bipartisan issue a very easy mistake to
make I often am out observing elections
on Election Day I usually vote absentee
ballot I get nervous every single time I
do it like have I gotten it all right
it's you know people worry about this
and they want to do it right but
sometimes they don't so this provides a
great opportunity for every vote to be
counted so thank you very much
questions from the committee
all right that was easy
um with that Q uh representative
grabbing the blue sheet
okay thank you this is yeah it's
extensive
um
so uh out of those who did not speak uh
one person signed in and they were for
it uh with that I will close the hearing
on House Bill 484 uh is it two o'clock
it is two o'clock uh we'll open up the
um we'll open up the hearing on House
Bill 495 relative to Counting votes
representative McGuire it's good to see
you again yes nice to see you
I have some extra handouts if anyone in
the audience would like
okay
all right everyone have their sheet okay
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan McGuire I represent the
town of Epsom
so the this is a non-partisan election
law bill it's it's a simple and
hopefully a little bit fun
um it stems from an experience I had
observing a recount
so if you've never done that before I
highly recommend that you go and watch a
recount because actually seeing actual
ballots tells you something about the
minds of Voters and things like that you
would think that it would be just very
dry but it actually isn't it's it's it's
interesting
um and and you know 98 or something of
all all uh ballots are voted normally
there's nothing weird about them and so
on but every once in a while there are
strange marks on the ballots and people
have to the people doing the counting
have to use some judgment about what was
the intention of the voter in that case
right so and when you're doing a recount
it's very important that every vote be
judged correctly and consistently
because that's a very close election I
mean by definition you're in a recount
because it's within a few votes of
deciding who wins so in this particular
recount that I was in watching years ago
if you look at the left hand side of
your page there was a ballot that looked
very much like that all right you see
this this is a a ballot from some
partisan voter right the the voters the
member of the dog party right and uh but
we were in we were recounting
um the election for executive counselor
in this case right so the question is is
this of is there a vote on this ballot
from for H Jones or not
okay and there's no right answer right
just think about it to yourself if you
were seeing this valid
um and and you were recounting the
executive counselor is it's either they
didn't vote for executive counselor or
they voted for H Jones right so the
question is which one is it and so when
I was watching I had in my mind that
they did not vote for H Jones in this
case
um but when this ballot went to the
Secretary of State to be counted the
Secretary of State said yes that's a
vote for H Jones okay and and I thought
well that's kind of weird right what's
the logic so so in my mind the logic is
this person clearly knows how to vote
you know simply and correctly uh their
pen didn't run out of ink or something
like that they started to vote for H
Jones right they circled the edge of the
bat of the circle but then they stopped
so they said maybe not right and so
therefore it's not a vote but but the
secretary do you have state ruled well
there's a there's a mark there so
therefore it is about right you know I
don't think there's a right or wrong
answer it's just it's just the point is
I think that two people doing this
process of of determining votes should
be do the same thing
right in in all cases if as possible
um two people looking at the same ballot
should come to the same conclusion all
right and therefore because right now
all we do is we say to the Secretary of
State or the moderator or the assistant
Secretary of State use your judgment
right and or the you know the the about
law commission use your judgment but I
think we could decide on judgment for
common cases like this one
so so that's what this bill does so this
bill picks lists a bunch of cases that
I've actually seen on ballots and you
could certainly I'd be perfectly happy
if you added other cases that you you
know of or you changed you know cases
that I've put on but it goes through and
says well in this case do this and in
this case do that and so on and if this
became law then then ballots would be in
recounts I mean this only really affects
recounts it has nothing to do with
machine voting but it's in recounts
um we would do something consistently
from one recount to the next which I
think would be Advanced an advantage so
what is the bill list well that's the
right hand column
so the bill basically says if everything
on the ballot is consistent except for
one spot or possibly two spots then the
bill applies right so if somebody votes
their whole ballot by doing slashes or
check marks or plus signs or whatever
they do if they do it consistently over
their whole ballot that's fine there's
no question about that it's only when
one particular spot or possibly two
spots is different than the rest of the
ballot then this bill the the actions of
this bill applies so what are things
that could be different well in this
case the person crossed off the name
they voted but then they crossed off the
name so according to the bill that would
be not a vote
in the second one the person would have
had an overvote but they did something
weird on one of them and so the one
that's weird is not a vote right so
therefore this would not be an over this
would be a vote for O Jones okay
in the third one they put a little dot
in the middle of their Circle so what
you find when you look at ballots is
sometimes people like touch their pen to
all the spots and then decide to fill in
right so just touching your pen in a
little dot when that's inconsistent with
the rest of the ballot that would not be
a vote
the fourth one is very common people
cross off votes and and vote elsewhere
so a cross-off this is not a vote this
is commonly done today
um common practice the fifth one is the
one we talked about I would say that's
not a vote uh the sixth one
this one I saw once
um it's a very weird one because they
they essentially decorated this
particular vote right so so I interpret
this as they really like this one right
you know this is this is a really good
one so so that one would be a vote and
and the seventh one is a write-in where
they forgot to fill in the circle so as
long as that doesn't create an overvote
I would say go ahead with the write-in
all right and that's what this bill does
okay questions and they're I'm sure you
know anything about election law we get
into this sort of stuff there's a lot of
questions uh representative O'Brien
thank you thank you to chairman
I like to go to uh the number six for S
Jones the one you I think it looks like
a spider
but you say that you think it means they
really like the person but couldn't it
also be interpreted as they really
changed their mind because they might
have filled in the oval and then started
Crossing it out
absolutely right you could decide to say
no to that one and I would be that would
be fine with me right I I'm only
interested in consistency but in this
particular case and in the ballot I saw
they did not vote for anyone else
right so it's a little different from
number four because they made it into a
sun or something right they made it into
what to me looks like you know extra
like but you know to you it could be a
CrossFit that's fine you know it it it's
all judgment
representative Baum
thank you Mr chairman now in in our town
when I've told a lot of Voters if you
make a mistake on the ballot ask for
another one so why wouldn't people
rather than
messing things up just ask for another
battle yes thank you for the question
and I agree with you absolutely and if
you look at line 14
um of the bill on the I guess the first
first page
um
I actually add that to the instructions
specifically the current instructions
don't say that and and uh so I say if
you incorrectly Mark your ballot you may
request a new ballot from the moderator
right so I think it's good to add the
instructions but obviously these are for
cases when they don't bother right so
thank you further questions
representative Grill
thank you Mr chair and thanks for taking
my question
um in terms of who would be
um responsible for making a judgment I
know at the end of election night um
there's the hand count process so um
so far we've discussed more when you
know during your recount when the
secretary of state is making a judgment
but would a moderator or um town clerk
also follow this bill in terms of making
those calls the answer is yes it's to be
consistent across the whole state yes
thank you further questions
representative Howard thank you Mr chair
and uh thank you for sharing your
testimony today I I wanted to ask how uh
what are the shortcomings in the ballot
law commissions decisions on any of
these markings on the on the ballot
um well thank you for the question I
don't know specifically about ballot law
commission decisions
um I know about the one case I told you
about this one on the left was the
Secretary of State's decision now I I
don't think that in that particular
election
after the recount I don't think it went
to the ballot law commission I think
there was enough votes one way or the
other that it was dispositive you know
what I mean so
um so you know I can't really answer but
but like I said specifically the
Secretary of State made a decision that
I would have made personally would have
made the opposite decision so that's the
basis
further questions representative Lane
thank you
um
I have done recounts and I have so and
you're right you see everything so so
what if this isn't everything and it
does your the bill doesn't seem to
address that so it would be up to the
discretion of the election officer to
make it in that instance yes thank you
for the question yes it would default
back to if it's not one of these things
discussed it would default back to the
moderator or the Secretary of State or
whatever no yes but if you can think of
others you know I'd be happy for you to
add them
just it's just led me to make all of a
decision
further I get a follow-up I was just a
fall it's not really a question but
um every time you do that you always
leave one out at least that's been my
experience yeah I'm not claiming these
are exhaustive it's it's the Royal you
um further questions representative
Muirhead
thank you um
so first uh
if if a voter puts a little dot in the
middle of the oval every time they vote
for candidate they'll vote for too many
then then all those little dots could
counter if they just trace the outline
of the oval those things okay so because
two to to be takes precedence over 2C as
it does logically okay yes do you just
happen to know how how an election how
those uh Optical readers see things like
the little dot in the middle of the
circle or the outline of the outsider
they count those as votes
um thank you for the question
um
I don't know for sure but I would I
would assume that on let's say my H
Jones case the optical reader might read
that as a blank right it might not have
I would assume they they look for some
some amount of dark right and and they
they have a threshold right of if it's
some more than this and less than that
and maybe they look at all the spots and
say Well they're all light therefore I
move my threshold down and you know I
mean if I were writing the software that
might be how I would do it right and if
they're all very dark I'll move my
threshold up right so so uh I can't
answer the question specifically but
uh you follow
I I'm tempted to ask a follow-up
question just do it just do it you know
why not we have we have another we have
another 13 minutes till the next one so
I mean do you know how chat GPT would
[Laughter]
does it have a camera input or something
it can
uh okay any other questions
representative McGuire
okay uh well thank you representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman we've got
one other card uh Dan Healy
I no longer speak then we have no cards
um I'll take the blue sheet
representative aikenberg
I don't remember
thank you okay of those
um signed up had not spoken
um wow
um
sorry did I miss you
oh yes you know we haven't closed it yet
so we haven't done that
so close don't worry unless you guys tie
up the deputy secretary um we're still
gonna have some time sorry Aaron
Hennessy deputy Deputy Terry State thank
you Mr chairman for my late remark I
just want to point out one thing in this
legislation and it goes to
representative Lane's question about
what if some an oval is not filled in
according to the examples that are
provided in the legislation and on lines
25 and 26 it says shall determine and
then blah blah blah as follows so it
doesn't it doesn't account for anything
other than what's one of the examples
given here so
um my concern is is that if somebody's
pen is running out of ink and in the
last two ovals there's just a little bit
of a dot in each left those would not be
counted as a vote because they don't
follow
what's here but when you look at the
ballot as a whole you can see the inks
running out which I've seen before
um but that doesn't fit into one of the
descriptions here and so those votes
wouldn't be counted so I just want to
say this is not an exhaustive list but
the language of the bill says that it
shall be counted according to only these
examples here okay questions
representative wood yes uh then it was
said that if we looked at the example
the first set of examples H Jones with
just a circle outline was selected by
the Attorney General as
Secretary of State sorry as as a valid
vote that's not one of the examples that
I've ever seen but can you help me with
that sorry I I'm only looking at the
legislation I don't have what you have
in front of oh I'm sorry can I hand it
to her yeah um go for it we got 35
minutes go for it
Fold It Up make origami do whatever you
got to do you know
the circle yes okay thank you so for H
Jones versus G Jones yes I've seen that
before
I've seen someone do this on a ballot
before and that's
if they were consistent with it
yesterday representative this doesn't
even begin to touch which you will see
on those ballots
representative weary
question just uh
uh would you rather see regulation or
guidance from the Secretary of State for
these type of examples
you have does the Secretary of State's
office have a preference
um thank you for the good question
um I would rather see guidance in the
election procedure manual versus
stipulation in law just because again
you're not going to have an exhaustive
list follow yeah so so just like
um line 14 on the first page so
I think the idea of of
regulating the requesting of a new
ballot is not a bad
thing but
but I I take I take it with some of the
the other that the guidance would be
perhaps preferable and
and I'm sure the office the Secretary of
State's office would have an even more
comprehensive list than the cat and dog
party examples
yes I'm sure if we got everyone around
and started chatting we would come up
with a really really long list of
possibilities
thank you
question sorry yeah Mike was off Mike
was on representative Lane thank you
so
ask that you provide guidance because I
know and I don't remember which other
bill it was but
um secretary Scanlon seemed to think he
needed some kind of authority to make
those regulations so would that be
something you think you would need
rather than itemize them out or not so
thank you for the question um no we
already do provide guidance in our
training sessions that we do we go
around the state and do trainings before
every Statewide election and that's when
I first started in this position having
no other election law experience
um and so that's how I learned about all
these different weird anomalies was in
the training and how to look at the
intent of the voter as a whole
where's the Murat thank you does the
guidance that we ought that your office
offers align with the guidance that's in
this bill
uh I would say in general yes
um I I can't say specifically I don't
have it in front of me but the intent of
when you look at someone how someone's
voting is always to look at what the
intent of the voter was so if they
I mean you will see a lot of different
stuff but if they've crossed out a name
and wrote definitely not ever you know
that representative Muirhead is familiar
with those on the ballots that he looks
at in his district
uh
I can I can get the committee what's in
the election
procedure oh you have the election
procedure manual but we go in beyond
what the procedure manual has in our
trainings we go into things like this
um in-person trainings
representative Brennan
thank you and thank you for taking my
question if this bill were to be amended
to keep the
line 1415 where it says if you
incorrectly Mark your ballot you may
request a new ballot from the moderator
so that that was part of the
instructions on the ballot and then
simply added that
[Music]
um
the that the Secretary of State's office
must provide specific guidance
on interpreting uh ballot marks
as part of the required part of the
training is that something that would
sufficiently address this issue
appropriately
thank you for the question I can't speak
to the sponsors response to that but I
think that since we do do that in our
trainings we we would be
happy with
that requirement
fair enough further questions
representative weary
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so just um
I I guess you know there can be a
difference between guidance or
guidelines and training training can go
and I'm thinking
I don't want to misinterpret what the
sponsor wants but it appears that they
want some kind of more detailed
um thing so is it possible to provide
that
more detailed guidance within the manual
or the materials Beyond just the
training seminars so that it's codified
in some way but not at the regulatory
level
thank you for the question
um
so this
and again I just got up to talk about
the shall part or the um as follows but
um you made a mistake I think the
difference between what the and I can't
speak to these sponsors intent but the
way this is written it's election
officials shall do this in our office we
provide training we provide forms and
guidance we put in an election that we
put it in the manual we put it in online
training we put it in person training
but we can't require election officials
to do something
so
for the questions
I'll follow up so
um
so do we so kind of teasing that out a
little bit then do we need to clarify
the language to say that election
officers will follow the guidance
provided by the Secretary of State's
office on this matter
I think I have to get back to you
I'm not sure that yeah I'd have to I
think that's more of a legal question
the Lord uh representative prude home
O'Brien thank you Mr chairman
I've seen
ballots that are filled out during a
recap when I was working a recount
and I remember
voting myself
correct me if I'm wrong but aren't there
instructions on the table that tell you
how to fill out the oval when you're
voting they're right there
so the voter can see that and would you
agree
with what I observed and that is that
New Hampshire voters are pretty good
I I don't I find these to be in a vast
minority stuff like this and what you
know what you're talking about thank you
for the question without statistically
looking at
our ballots I would definitely agree
with you from the recounts that I've
seen that it's this paper is
um not the norm of Voters
and that there are instructions in the
ballot booth and I believe those
instructions also say you can get if you
make a mistake you can get a new ballot
yes oh sorry he's saying you can get up
to three ballots yeah yes
further questions for the definition of
shall
okay
thank you deputy secretary thank you uh
you know the answer to that
um
on the blue sheet we have
three people signed up uh not testifying
all of which were opposed and with that
I will close the hearing on HB 495 we
will reconvene at three o'clock
um for our final bill of the day which
is three HB 460. thank you
foreign okay
all right here you hear you
um going to I'm gonna I'm gonna open up
the house election law committee on
house bill 460. one two three four five
um
yeah is the representative Lynn
um before we start looks like we're
gonna have quite a few pink cards so we
can get those down to me real fast
um
your head Russ
how dare you
um okay so it looks like we have quite a
few people sign up to speak on this
um so with the um uh ranking members
Indulgence I am going to put in a time
limit for each speaker not including the
primary sponsor it was the own objection
of that
it depends on how long the primary
sponsor is given I think both sides need
to be have equal time to be heard okay
um if that's the case we'll put in a
five minute limit for everyone
does that work for you representative
one
oh yes absolutely it does and we have a
card for you representative way no you
don't and I'm I'm filling it out right
now
afterwards and you start it up
and I'll get my clock going here
all right
um
well thank you uh Mr chair members of
the committee um
actually this this bill
I think is relatively simple
um and and I'll I think I can explain it
fairly simply
my intent in drafting this bill
was simply to set to to say we want to
preserve
New Hampshire same day registration
to allow people to come in and register
on the same day that they vote even if
they haven't done so earlier we want to
preserve
the sort of
uh
pre-same day registration the same as it
kind of exists now but the one thing
that we want to do away with
is
the sort of excuses if you will for not
providing the required documentation to
prove
citizenship domicile age and identity
and essentially what this build does is
it does away with all that it says you
want to come in and register on Election
Day great
bring the documents if you don't bring
the documents you don't vote it's as
simple as that and this and obviously on
an earlier day if you register before
election day then you don't have to
prove again on Election Day your
citizenship or your domicile
um or that kind of thing all you need to
prove is your identity on Election Day
and that's really that's that's sort of
the end of it it's it basically says we
have voter ID and we really mean it you
you don't get to say if you don't show
up with your identification well I
really am trust me we don't we don't you
don't do that you you provide the
documentation or you don't vote
I'll be happy to take questions well
that was easy you're well within your
limit uh questions from the committee
representative Lane
um thank you Mr chair thank you very
much I'm not counting questions in
anyone's time
um so opening five minutes opening Salvo
however long the questions go the
questions go
evidence that the existing law has been
abused or if anyone or if there's
widespread
um fraud in connection with this
existing law that there's widespread
fraud no I've actually the existing law
with the with the affidavit ballot that
we now have now has not actually been
used yet
um but if you're asking is there
existing is there widespread existing
fraud the real answer is I don't know
and the problem the problem is that the
election laws the way they exist now
make it pretty hard make it pretty hard
to prove fraud I mean we've had we've
seen a few cases of people voting you
know who have voted voted multiple times
and have been and have been charged with
it but as a practical matter it's pretty
hard to prove fraud so so the fact that
you know we have we don't have a ton of
cases I'm not sure I guess I would I
guess I would agree it probably means
that there's not widespread fraud it
doesn't mean that there may not be a
fair amount of fraud that we just don't
know about
follow up
thank you representative is there uh I
guess to focus on uh double voting I'm
talking about with the affidavits is
there anyone that you're aware of that
has been prosecuted or has there been
evidence that someone has voted when
they weren't supposed to when they
signed an affidavit when they signed it
after I'm frankly not sure about the
people who were prosecuted whether they
had signed an affidavit or not
um about as to their identity but I do
know that that from from what I've heard
from both the Attorney General's office
and secretary of state is that they've
had they've had a fair amount of
difficulty in following up there have
been a number of cases where they have
not been able to follow up on people who
said who filed affidavits which I think
is is a worrying circumstance
representative weary
okay just follow up on thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
can I just follow up on that comment you
made about the attorney general and the
Secretary of State not right following
up could you expand on that a little bit
or you know is that lack of resources is
that lack of
time to pursue whether or not these
affidavits are valid no I'm sorry you
know I guess maybe I I misspoke a little
bit when I when I when I said not follow
up what I meant was it's my
understanding that there have been a
number of situations in which this I
either the Secretary of State or the
attorney general has sent out the you
know the follow-up letters that are
supposed to be said and they have not
been they have not been returned
indicating that you know confirming the
person's address as an example now there
may there may also be other it I I don't
mean to say that the attorney general
and the Secretary of State have you know
in every case uh sent out the letter I
just don't know the answer to that
question
hello thank you okay and further
questions from the committee
representative Hamlet thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
so on page nine
under Section seven voting procedure
obtaining a ballot amend RSA 659 13 2B
does you know what I can you tell me
again the section because I I don't have
the same copy of the bill that you do it
I think it's RSA 659 colon 13
Roman numeral two B okay
reported McDonald's
yeah sorry about that tell them I say
hello
[Laughter]
I will have to call him back
turn this off
sorry about that
no yes I'm sorry okay so 13 uh 2B so
does this
change remove and election officials
ability to verify the identity of a
voter
no it would not no in fact I thought I
had I thought there's
there should be language in there that
says
um
the election official specifically
has the authority to do that I believe I
mean that the old okay and follow-up
question
yes I'm sorry I was just discovering I
was struggling to find that section
because I was reading the wrong bill so
okay okay so I'm sorry follow-up
question so I don't know I I guess I'm
confused so
yes you do say that the moderator or
supervisor to the checklist or Clerk
um has the authority
to verify a voter
and but then it says
um
as if no verification was made so
someone can challenge the voter will be
required to execute a challenge but or
affidavit as if no verification was made
and then the rest of the section is
crossed out
you know what uh you know representative
I think
I I filed with the committee an
amendment to the original bill
um which I I thought I sent to all
members of the committee it's Amendment
the amendment number is 2023
0208h and it
when when I got the original Bill back
from OLS
that it was it was like 90 right but
there were a couple of sections sort of
towards the end that I I'm not quite
sure what what happened but there were
some mistakes and it was it was so close
to the deadline that I just you know I
said I approve and I'll make the changes
later and then I did make them and I
thought I had sent that amendment to all
members of this committee if I didn't I
apologize and I will certainly get it to
you but it made it it it made some of
the it sounds some of the language that
you were reading about you know
affidavit ballot I that that was some of
the language that was left in by mistake
and I took out so I think now with the
with the amendment it it does sort of
straighten out that problem I believe
okay thank you I haven't seen the
amendment okay I apologize for that as I
say I thought I sent it to all members
in the committee a while ago but I
believe our clerk has it and she is
going to distribute it to us shortly
okay um I have not seen the amendment
um further questions from the committee
um thank you you and thank you again
um there's a lot of expansion in the
bill
about challenges and how those work
can you give a rationale for those
particularly if they're happening on the
same day as as the election sure I mean
I guess what the what the um
the
the bill doesn't change
existing law all that much with regard
to the way challenges are made but it's
it's simply I mean the main change that
it says is if if a challenge is made and
the grounds for the challenge
don't really change you know what they
are under existing law but if they're if
a challenge is made then the mod the
moderator or election official makes the
decision on the challenge and if that is
if the if a person whoever is not happy
with that decision has an immediate
opportunity to go to Superior Court to
challenge it
um that that part the immediately going
to Superior Court is is is new
um because under the you know under you
that was less necessary under the system
where you had this affidavit ballot and
a certain waiting period so this
provides for an immediate challenge to
the Superior Court
um that's that's I guess I would say
that's probably the main the main
difference
thank you
um so if you're voting at six o'clock at
night and you weren't challenged
Superior Court is closed and the
election is going to close in an hour or
two is that really a remedy that's gonna
work sure you know I I mean I I guess I
agree with you that that you know that
could present a problem in that
circumstance you know I
what all of this incl including the no
excuse absentee I mean no excuse uh uh I
voter identification
I think one of the things that it says
and I think it's entirely proper to say
this is
you know we want voting to be
open and accessible and all that but it
doesn't mean that you know it's that you
don't have to exercise some
responsibility so that maybe it means if
you know that you you know you don't
have identification or that there's some
that there might be some reason for your
being challenged maybe you ought to get
to the polls a little earlier
um that's you know and and if and I
suppose if you had a situation where
somebody you know it really was a
circumstance where a challenge just kind
of came out of the blue
um and it was and it was late and the
person couldn't get that challenge in
superior court within the time you know
before the polls closed I suppose if it
was a valid challenge the person could
go to Superior Court and have and have a
ruling that the person's vote would
count and you know I suppose again in
the unlikely circumstance that it made a
difference
um that maybe you know maybe that would
change the result of an election
I think that's unlikely but it possibly
could happen
further questions representative
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
when a voter signs an affidavit is it
not true that they are signing in
accordance with RSA 659 colon 34 the
penalty for knowingly and purposely
providing false information when
registering to vote or voting is a class
A misdemeanor with obviously penalties
Associated for violating the law right
is that oh that's true you know the the
perjury is is one of the most difficult
things to prove and so you know as a
practical matter perjury happens in the
courts a lot and it never gets
prosecuted because it's very hard to
prove
um and so you know it would it uh it it
it is is the the need to sign an
affidavit under oath a deterrent yeah I
would agree it's some deterrent it's
certainly better than not having not
saying anything but is it you know does
it is it is it a better alternative than
requiring somebody to provide
identification doesn't come close in my
view
follow up please and are you aware of
any evidence to suggest that
there is a major issue with our Avid
affidavit process am I aware of any
evidence that as I said before I don't
know on the cases that have been
prosecuted involving somebody who voted
more than once
whether any of those had filed
affidavits and I also don't I don't have
an answer but I think the very fact that
we asked the question raises an issue in
itself of the all the you know
verification letters that are sent out
and have not been returned
um those you know I don't again I don't
know how many of them there are but my
understanding from the reading from the
Press is that there have been a fair
number of those and so again that raises
a question of
where are those people who are those
people
further questions from the committee
yes representative Bay
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
in your response to representative
Brennan uh with regard to uh
it being hard to prove perjury are you
implying that maybe one of the intents
for this bill is because of the weakness
of our justice system I'm sorry the the
weakness because the weakness the
weakness justice system
I mean I suppose in some sense it's hard
you know I'm not quite sure
how we
how we make it less difficult to prove
perjury that but but to the extent that
you say that's a weakness in the justice
system I guess I agree with it
thank you
okay further questions from the
committee
um I have a few
first one is so I'm looking at how
you've restructured the
um
the identification you have to prove to
provide citizenship So currently you
have to provide citizenship
um It's actually kind of hard
um you have to basically produce
effectively two government documents so
if I think like that uh yours actually
makes it easier to prove citizenship you
may you are taking
um
basically you're putting at least my
understanding of this bill is is the
citizenship would be underneath the same
requirement as section D on the second
page lines 23 so you take a photo
driver's license issued by any federal
or state government United States
passport service identification photo
notification photo application issued by
state or local government or any other
evidence that reasonably establishes
that it is more than likely that it's
more likely than not that the person is
who he or she claims to be so basically
you're saying if they show up with
anything
that is reasonable we're going to let
them vote no that's you know what you're
reading under the identities that's how
you prove identity okay so this is for
when they're that's for identity so what
is it for registration first for
citizenship
the supervisor it's in subsection 1A on
the first page the supervisors of the
checklist or the town or city clerk
shall accept from the applicant any one
of the following as proof of citizenship
the applicant's birth certificate
passport naturalization papers if the
applicant is a naturalized citizen or
any other reasonable documentation which
indicates the applicant is a United
States citizen and it's although it
seems to me that you know there I mean
to some extent if if the current law
does not have that last clause about any
other reasonable documentation then you
know then I guess I would agree that
this does open up the categories of how
you prove citizenship I'm just not sure
what the uh if the current loss has has
uh the catch-all phrase that is in this
bill I don't know if it does or not um
that's a great question I don't know at
the top of my head I thought it didn't
but I definitely reserve the right to be
wrong about that
um and one final question so you were a
judge
um you deal with prosecutors how do you
find somebody uh who's committed a crime
perjury Class A misdemeanor uh when you
don't have their name their address or
any other piece of information from them
other than a signature on a piece of
paper
pretty hard okay pretty hard to uh
pretty hard to to get that information
to make a prosecution thank you uh
further questions
all right thank you thank you uh it's
always hard for me to call
Representative Justice Lynn
but Bob is fine thank you very much okay
um we've got quite a few people assigned
to speak let me kind of address how I
ordered these
um I did state representatives first
only one that's pretty common in
practice uh after that I did names that
I didn't recognize uh so we'll call up
not our frequent flyers uh welcome to
election law and then after that anyone
who is here on behalf of an organization
uh is going towards the tail end uh
because you're probably probably getting
paid so you can hang out
um so uh not everybody to be fair not
everybody but you you are here versus
our normal people uh so the first one uh
representative uh pope of each Mueller
Popovich Mueller
thank you very much Mr chair
um using my cell phone to time myself I
want to stick to the three minutes I uh
generally set as the maximum timeline
hard as it may be to believe my intent
when co-sponsoring this bill is to have
it as a non-partisan bill I do recognize
this is not how it's seen by a lot of
the people in the room I'm not that
naive but as far as I can tell we all
have an interest in making sure our
elections are run the right way and that
the right people who have the right to
vote vote and the people who don't have
the right to vote are not allowed to
vote
I'm a naturalized citizen
came from Eastern Europe Romania may as
well ruin the whole against Daniel's
action game for everybody
but I spend a long time working towards
my citizenship and I think we should
make it easier for people to get
naturalized but that's a different story
what I want to tell you is what happened
to me when I went to register as a voter
in Walton Massachusetts where I lived at
the time
it's around 2008 I finally get my
naturalization certificate literally the
next day I walk with it proudly to the
city hall and say I want to be
registered as a voter and I put the
naturalization certificate on the desk
and the nice lady who worked the desk
literally walked back and just hands up
and said you have to remove that from my
counter like what are you talking about
well it's your naturalization
certificate we are not allowed to look
at those
what do you mean
well you know you just file an affidavit
the city specifically says you are not
allowed to check even if it's offered
you may not look at the documents I
swear to God this is exactly what
happened to me personally this is not a
story from somebody else this is my
personal experience
and I'm like how do you know people
don't lie on the affidavit and they say
oh it's a ten thousand dollar fine
nobody would risk that
so of course I asked them so how many of
those did you issue
you all know the answer is zero already
right
this is
both a true story and my answer to the
ones of you that ask well can you prove
there is a problem
there are sometimes situations in which
systems are set up that it is impossible
to measure the problem because there is
no way to actually
capture the data how am I gonna
find out who the people are and whether
they broke the law if I cannot find them
after they voted if they are gone from
whatever the address they said they were
gonna live in how do I locate them to
establish who they were and I don't know
of any way to fix that
other than maybe use all those you know
letters of confirmation that we sent and
hopefully use it as a proxy for people
that are suspicious
but I agree that not that's not very
good data
the intent of this legislation is not to
disenfranchise anyone and I say that as
a co-sponsor of this legislation and I
swear to God that's true this being said
is it possible to come up with a
scenario in which somebody who should be
a voter due to a certain set of
circumstances may be unable to vote at
some point
of course we can hypotheticals are fun
and we can always argue over How likely
they are
when we try to pass legislation we have
to look at it as
on the balance does the good does it do
that it does outweigh the potential
negative consequences that are not in
the spirit of the law
it is my honest belief that this
legislation if passed will have good
consequences that will outweigh the bad
I also recognize that a lot of the
people I spoke with you know for half an
hour at 9 30 this morning that were
holding signs opposing this bill Phil
otherwise and I recognize that's a
difference
and I respect that but where I'm coming
from based on all the data and my
experience I believe this to be a bill
where the good outweighs the bad I
really appreciate you allowing me to
cheat a little bit on the three minutes
it was not International thank you it's
okay you still have 40 seconds
um questions from the committee
uh represent around thank you and thank
you for taking my question
um we're in the middle of a housing
crisis here in New Hampshire
do homeless folks have the right to vote
I believe that as long as they are
residents of the state and that they are
citizens of the US absolutely they have
the right to vote Yes they should meet
the four criteria but you know what the
four criteria are thank you follow up
please yep
and
is it your interpretation of this bill
that
someone who is currently without a home
and without perhaps a legal address
without a utility bill would this bill
make it harder or easier for them to
vote
I would expect that as long as the state
is willing to provide them with a
documentation that they are State
residents it should be a very simple
manner for them to provide that they are
eligible to vote we already have statute
that statutes that regulate you know how
to handle people without a clear address
and I would expect those to apply also I
want to make it very clear and actually
thank you for asking the question
because I did forget to mention a very
important point
I would strengthen us strenuously argue
that any ID that may be required to
comply with this registration should not
have any fear associated with it in this
case a driver's license I would expect
that you know the state would have to
provide that for free because uh you
know it's not okay to have any kind of
financial obstacle in the way of voting
further questions from the committee
representatively
um
with regard to your last comment thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking
the question
um right now that is not the case the
state does not provide that and homeless
and low-income folks are most hurt by
that they often cannot get to the city
clerk's office or the Town Hall that's
only open certain times because they're
working two or three jobs
so
when I read this bill and I know it's
not your intent but does it not seem
that you are excluding some people who
cannot get that kind of ID
who who do not have a lot of the
Comforts that I have
and we're excluding them from voting and
is that worth it to exclude those folks
in order to get this bill
I really appreciate the question
and first let me State for the record
that absolutely it is not the intent of
the bill to exclude anyone if somebody
has legitimate
difficulties complying with the
requirements I would expect that between
State support and you know town is
offering support and Charities and
everything we should be able to make
everybody you know
meet the requirements needed to register
and vote the expenditures are not really
material in any way shape or form we are
just talking about speaking for my town
which of course is one town in the state
and the other towns are different but in
my town
the town will happily give you a ride
you know if you're a senior or if you're
a person who needs a ride there are
progress where you can call and they
will come and pick you up and drive you
anywhere you can go to the town hall and
get a piece of paper from the clerk
saying that you cannot pay for your
driver's license and the DMV will take
care of that for you
but again I I recognize that some people
may have difficulty you know accessing
those types of services this being said
I think the way to address that which I
would fully support you know legislative
and personal is to make sure those
services are provided rather than avoid
passing you know this bill I you know
I fully support making every effort to
allow every person who is should be who
is allowed to vote to vote
I worked very hard for my right to vote
I would never take it from anybody who's
entitled to it
some further questions from the
committee I'm represent Hamer
[Music]
and has a terrific record of finding
voters who have used the affidavits for
proof of voting for proof of residency
they honestly the only Dick Tracy that I
know of is a fictional character so the
answer to the first part of the question
is no
my concerns are
that while Mr Tracy or his colleagues
may do an exceptional job and I have no
reason to question that
I think those questions a lot of the
times do not get asked because it's very
hard for the supervisors of the
checklist given the limited resources
and time they have to even identify you
know all the possible situations in
which these things may happen it has
been my experience in general that when
instance is a potential voter fraud have
been referred to the AG's office the
answer the outcome of those referrals
has been inconsistent as far as I would
like to see it I'm aware of times when
they didn't pursue things when I think
they should have pursued them and I'm
sure that they have pursued things that
I don't know about where you know they
also did a great job but
again
it's it's a concern when there is a
gaping hole in our voting laws and by
the way
I knocked on about 2 900 dollars to get
elected to this 100 a year job
and um
the vast majority of people I spoke
about and I brought up the voter ID laws
we're not even aware that voter IDs are
not mandatory already because every time
they go to vote they get asked for their
ID they provide it and that's it
the vast majority of residents don't
know about it and at least from the over
a thousand people that actually opened
the door and spoke with me the vast
majority of them were in disbelief that
this is allowed mind you I knocked on
specific doors in town
other doors may have gotten different
answers but I literally had two people
who said I cannot support you because
you believe about in voter ID
president Brennan
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um representative Lynn who's introduced
the bill was unaware of how many
affidavit
um
affidavits had not been
cured by the AG's office are you aware
of how many outstanding affidavits are
flying in unknown territory
no
follow-up please
yes
so
this bill
would be attempting to solve a problem
that we don't really know is
an issue
of course we know it's an issue we just
don't know how big necessarily
I agree
and I conceded from the beginning that
the way system is set up it is very hard
to measure what the impact is because of
just the nature of you know people
without an ID you know disappearing into
the night and good luck finding them
the other thing that I would submit for
your consideration is that
we fix laws not only because they get
grievously abused but it also because
there is the potential for future abuse
or you know increased abuse in the
future do we wait until you know
it's terrible until we fixed what I
believe to be an obvious problem I don't
think that's the right approach but I do
agree that you know it is absolutely
difficult to measure the scope of this
yes
further questions all right sing them
thank you
um thank you no other state
representatives are signed up to speak
so we're going on to the citizenry uh
first up is Curtis register from Durham
New Hampshire
no
good afternoon make sure you press the
button right in front of you
there you go
good afternoon honorable members of the
election uh law committee I'm very
honored to be here and I'm very grateful
to have the moment to speak with you my
name is Curtis register this is Lord
Remington register he's the more
important member of uh this discussion
but we are both residents of Durham New
Hampshire uh and I stand in steadfast
opposition to HB 460. now uh
this is the bill that seeks to solve a
problem that doesn't exist
especially in New Hampshire
and it adds obstacles to voters without
means and persons of color
investigative journalists from AP
Washington Post and then reinforced by
the ACLU
went through a comprehensive
investigation and reviewed 22 years of
voting history in the United States
national elections and found 500 cases
of voter fraud that were credible in 500
years even or in 22 years even less than
were actually convicted with evidence
in contrast voter ID laws Across the
Nation that has become a nice Trend uh
have thrown out thousands of votes each
election with a fantastic grand total
coming out of our favorite state of
Texas of a whopping 18
000 votes in one election in March
in addition to voter ID laws coming from
a legacy of voter suppression and racism
which can be found with research in the
ACLU Brennan law of election uh
and from many law professors from many
universities to include Harvard
with many working deliberately to
alienate and refute minority votes
there is a cost associated with voter ID
laws
not just the cost that's incurred by the
individual that has to go and get an ID
and go through all the logistics of
making sure their paperwork is in a row
so the individual doesn't turn them away
at the desk as the cost incurred by the
state
I see on the on the hb460 that we did a
nice uh Financial worksheet here
that has fiscal years 23 24 and 25
coming out at a a boon for the budget of
a couple hundred thousand dollars
Texas when they implemented theirs back
in 2015
had to pay up to 2 million dollars
in education
and in training for their election
workers
and that's without giving them IDs to
their voters
Indiana
in 2014 when they also put their voter
ID law into effect had to give 10
million dollars
and training
election day training and education as
well as funding
licenses to uh the citizens that need to
vote and this is all online ACLU is what
I use to find the sources that link to
the supporting documentation
but this is a lot of costs that's
incurred
for a citizen to be able to execut
execute their right to vote
this does the opposite of increasing
voter confidence
it adds a variable of uncertainty
of if the form of identification is
going to be accepted if the voter
registration went through or is up to
date I myself have experienced
uncertainty and I'm as uh you know like
of means and capable of getting an ID as
anybody else and it was still fairly
nerve-wracking to go and get registered
to vote because you have you worry
you're concerned that your vote's not
going to count
it opens the door for more Extreme
Measures for voter suppression
voter ID laws are a current Trend but
they're not new they've been around for
a very long time
and voter ID laws happen to end up being
a gateway drug
to more extreme forms of voter
suppression
and now we've seen some measures back in
1966 you have the Harper V Board of
Virginia Board of Education incurring
that the 14th Amendment invokes no poll
tax though this is not a direct poll tax
it ties up under an indirect poll tax
just as awareness you have about 30
seconds left sir Roger that there are
ways to shore up our already secure
elections the New Hampshire campaign for
voting rights has put out information to
push out there as well as the Secretary
of State of New Hampshire who had their
special session on voter confidence that
listed a whole Myriad of fantastic ideas
to include
updating modernizing election equipment
respecting our election officials paying
them what they're worth and helping
support them when controversy arises
as well as post-selection audits we've
heard the sponsors today
there is no data to support this bill
from their own mouths
New Hampshire elections are safe this
bill solves nothing vote down HB 460.
thank you very much will you be taking
questions I will take whatever questions
you want to throw at me yes
representative Howard
thank you Mr chair and uh thank you for
coming and sharing your testimony today
I was wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit further on some of the uh
laws that you kind of described or uh
not necessarily described but alluded to
in uh in your previous statement so
Texas implemented a voter ID law that
was photo ID only in 2015 Indiana did
something similar uh outside of the
Google machine I can't give you any more
than that
yeah further questions from the
community representative weary
oh thank you thank you Mr chair thank
you for your testimony
uh do you have any documented cases of
voter suppression
from New Hampshire negative
thank you
further questions
thank you so much thank you
next up is Linda Bundy
thank you
yeah
welcome to election law thank you
good afternoon
Mr chair and members of house election
law committee my name is Linda Bundy and
I'm from Antrim
I oppose HB 460 relative to eliminating
voter identification ex exceptions
New Hampshire elections are safe and
secure
confirmed by bipartisan leaders
committees and members of the public
this bill eliminates a legitimate
process for voters who either don't have
or have forgotten documents needed to
register by repealing the rsas governing
the use of the challenged voter
affidavit
an affidavit is a serious legal document
when voters sign affidavits they are
swearing and affirming the truth of
their statements
the New Hampshire Office of the Attorney
General checks all affidavits to verify
voters identities conviction of lying on
an affidavit results in a fine of up to
five thousand dollars and up to one year
in jail
removing exceptions for proving voter
identification and voter affidavits as
proof of identification makes this bill
a form of voter suppression
the groups of Voters most of most
affected by this are the elderly new
Americans and houseless individuals
affidavits have been proven to be a safe
and secure way for voters to exercise
their right to cast a ballot
election Integrity relies on all
qualified voters being able to
participate in the process
limiting access to the vote weakens our
democracy
I ask that you vote in expedient to
legislate on HB 460.
thank you for this opportunity to speak
excellent will you be taking questions
no thank you all right next up is
Elizabeth Corell
okay
uh you turned it off so hit it again
there you go thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Elizabeth Carrell I live here in Concord
and I sit before you because I serve as
a supervisor of the checklist so I can
just um share some of my observations
and experiences in that capacity
generally I oppose this idea because I
think there are many messages we've
received over a long-term period of time
now I have been serving more than a
Dozen Years
um
for many quarters but I'm thinking about
the Secretary of State in particular
for probably the last four years they
have really impressed upon us as
supervisors do not send voters away when
they don't have the right documentation
there was a time when we might say well
do you have something in your car do you
have your car registration
why don't you go out and get it kind of
thing we are not supposed to be doing
that much more recently they've been
saying don't send them away have them do
the paperwork if you send them away they
may not come back and the message there
has been consistent we want them to vote
we don't want to present obstacles now
I'm talking about all the varieties of
affidavits
very often someone will come in and they
think they have what they need
um they've in cases they've voted before
they just haven't necessarily voted
where they are you know whether they're
coming from out of state or from another
part of the state
the other factor that I would raise to
you and perhaps to one or more of our
sponsors is we'll value voting but we
don't all think about it the way you and
I sitting around these tables do a lot
of people participate in the even year
elections we know voter turnout is huge
for a presidential
it's pretty high for the state elections
and pretty low for the municipal
especially if you're a city as opposed
to a town
the average person isn't tuned into the
it the way you and I are if they're
going to vote and they're not going to
think about what does it take to vote
they're thinking about who are they
going to vote for
and they know what time they're going to
vote often you know you have the early
comers who do it before work but you
have a lot of people ask anybody who
works at the polls who come in after
work
and after work varies depending on where
they live they may be coming in at 6 15
because they're coming from out of town
they work out of town they're in a rush
you tell that person they don't have the
right thing and they don't have the
option now you might say well why don't
they know what the problem is they've
voted so many times
well let me remind you we've just been
through a census
in my ward so I'm in Ward 5 and Concord
we used to operate right behind City
Hall
my ward location changed how many people
came in the door of our Ward
for that election
and they came to the wrong place so
first of all they're in the wrong place
now they have to get over the other site
and we have to make sure they know where
that is because there's been a Juggle
that's a result of the census
and the result of the decision the city
made about where the sites would be
that has nothing to do with their
ability to vote the census created
another challenge some people got
dropped
and try as any City Hall might mistakes
are made
we had voters who have always voted in
the same ward and two elections in a row
their name's not on the list now try
telling them they don't have the right
documentation to vote I mean really if
you want to see anger that's where
you're going to see it because they're
the ones who have always voted and
they've always shown up at what they
understood to be the right place and now
they're being told nah you can't do it
I I think the underlying message that I
would share though is as supervisors as
moderator clerk the whole Spectrum we're
there to serve and we've been told we're
here to help enable people to vote don't
create obstacles try to help them
achieve this
and with that I think setting in rules
like this do just the opposite so I
would suggest you oppose this
legislation
okay will you be taking questions yes
are there any questions from the
committee
oh yes uh representative Brennan thank
you and thank you for taking my question
it's voting right
or a privilege
well in my opinion it's a right uh that
you can exercise
um
as a citizen of the country
follow-up please yes
does this bill make it
easier or more difficult to exercise the
right to vote
it's putting some obstacles in the way
of some people who should be able to
vote in my view thank you further
questions from the committee
okay uh thank you thank you
um next up is
sales
um so the so the committee knows I'm
going to have to depart here because
unfortunately I have to go to something
that actually will pay me 100 a year
um normally representative Bowman would
take over at my stud but he is not here
so uh representative pruhome O'Brien
when she returns uh will be in charge of
the clock
and and you may go
good afternoon members of the committee
uh I'm sales castan I live in Dover I'm
here representing New Hampshire youth
movement and I'm here to testify an
opposition of hb460
the most accessible part of our voting
system is that voters can register at
the polls with few barriers through a
safe secure and efficient affidavit
process when necessary we should not put
that process in Jeopardy by passing
hb460
personally I've volunteered my time to
help community members and my peers vote
since my first election when I was 18
years old currently I'm affiliated with
New Hampshire youth movement
while New Hampshire youth movement does
endorse candidates the majority of our
work on college campuses is nonpartisan
we provide information and how and when
to vote and provide and direct voters to
free rides to the polls regardless of
the candidates they vote for or the
issues that are important to them
I personally have spent my time in three
elections giving rise to the polls to
voters who didn't have cars I didn't ask
who they were voting for and for when I
gave them a ride nor would I deny any
voter a ride if I knew they were voting
for a candidate I did not support I do
this because I believe that every
eligible voter ought to be able to vote
in an easy and safe process and that no
one should be denied that opportunity
for something like not having a car or a
bike
I know for my time working with
first-time voters there's already a lot
of confusion about voting many possible
voters do not know when where and
importantly for today what materials
they need to register to vote to People
Like Us who are deeply engaged in
politics it's easy to forget that most
people don't think about things like
voter registration until election day or
a few days before and newer voters are
not familiar with the registration or
absentee process unless someone has
taken the time to walk them through it
specifically the barriers related to
registration disproportionately affect
voters who move a lot renters students
new New Hampshire citizens and people
who work who move for work like travel
nurses and those in the military because
they constantly have to re-register at
the new address
hb460 would place a burden on these
people by limit by eliminating a
time-tested affidavit system that gives
law-abiding voters a way to prove their
identity if they don't have other
documents available when registering we
should oppose laws that make it harder
for eligible voters to navigate the
registration and voting processes
I am proud to say that in New Hampshire
we currently have strong safeguards at
every stage of the voting process to
guarantee safe and accurate elections
however we do not have a system that is
easily navigable by a sizable chunk of
eligible voters I believe and experts
agree that we can have accessibility and
safety but HP 460 would not make our
election safer and instead would make
them less accessible we have already we
already have a secure and reasonably
accessible voter registration process we
should not put that process in jeopardy
with this bill please oppose HP 460.
thank you
there any questions
with that thank you thank you
hi hi Mr chairman committee thank you
for taking my testimony today
um my name is Louise Spencer I am
co-founder of the Ken Street Coalition
which is an all-volunteer Grassroots
organization I'm not paid to be here
today
and I just want to start off by saying I
I think I have a
very different sense of Voters and then
some have expressed which is I've done a
lot of work at the polls I've done a lot
of canvassing
most people really want to vote and
really want to participate the people
that show up are there because they
think it's their Duty as a citizen and
they do that in good faith
so I'm very opposed to a bill that would
put obstacles in the way of Voters who
are otherwise qualified to vote
um
I am also I do want to make clear today
that I am speaking on behalf of the
chemistry Coalition this is a very
um big priority for our organization to
oppose this bill
um I know it's hard for some of us to
imagine just how difficult it might be
for people to have some of the documents
that are required by this bill that
includes the housing insecure or those
with no housing those who have lost
important documents Through Fire flood
or other natural disasters new Americans
especially young adult voters whose
parents might have the documents and
victims of domestic violence it also
presents challenges for seniors and for
those with disabilities I want to tell a
story about a man I recently met in
Concord who was house lit who did not
have a home he was holding a sign that
said need work no ID he had lost access
to his important documents including his
driver's license when he broke up with
his girlfriend they have been living
together and she refused to return any
of his documents or their possessions
in addition he was estranged from his
his parents and was not sure
if they had a copy of his birth
certificate because we talked about
voting he wasn't even sure what town he
or state he was born in
um so he wasn't sure where to go to
apply to get a duplicate certificate he
had gone to the DMV several times to get
a replacement license but without these
other documents he was unable to do so
I was aware that the Concord coalition
to end homelessness provided help to
people like this man and so I he took me
up on his the offer to drive him over
there and was thrilled that there might
be someone who could finally help him
navigate this process
we spoke to a representative at the
Coalition and they said it it is often a
several months-long process
um
a friend's parents recently lost their
home in the Colorado fires fortunately
they had all their documents together
but
some of their friends and others they
knew escaped with barely their lives
they did not have any of their documents
they then entered into a horrible
catch-2 Catch-22 situation where they
were unable to to get the documents they
needed to proceed forward with their
lives
some places let a parent swear to you
know where you were born you can do that
they can do an affidavit for you but a
lot of these folks were in their 80s
their parents were no longer living
I also checked with an immigration
attorney about for those people that
might have lost or not had access to
their naturalization certificates
to get a replacement with the n565 is
555 dollars plus some additional fees
bringing the cost to about 700 and it's
a 10 to 12 month processing time
and not everyone has a passport in fact
it appears currently it's hard to get
the specific data that about half of
Americans have valid passports some may
have expired passports but it leaves a
good number of people who don't have
that option approving citizenship
since
2006 the Heritage Foundation has cited
20 cases of voter fraud in New Hampshire
that have been successfully
um
verified
um and that's out of millions of votes
cast Over multiple elections
um
I want to ask the question we've heard
that it's hard to verify you know what
the voter fraud might be it's much
harder to verify the voter
disenfranchisement who are the people
that are not going to be able to uh that
get turned away we might be able to
count some of those people but what
about the people who say oh I don't have
a birth certificate I'm not going to go
or who feel overwhelmed I've talked to
plenty of those people at the door who
really feel like voting registering to
vote is a very complex and difficult
process how many people who are
legitimately qualified constitutionally
qualified in our state to vote are not
going to be able to vote that's what's
going to sway our elections not the
occasional person who perhaps
you know perhaps you know one of these
20 there's never been an indication that
it's swayed actually swayed an election
Secretary of State Bill Gardner qualif
um
spoke to that issue
I also want to point out that an
affidavit is a document it's a piece of
paper that you sign and it's a legal
document signed under penalty of law
and finally I want to point out that I
have seen those people as an election
Observer I'm at the polls almost every
election every election in all the towns
I've been at not through malfeasance or
I'm not accusing anybody of trying to
purposely drop people from the rolls but
people get dropped for whatever reason
and those people are not showing up with
their documentation thinking they're
going to have to re-register and as one
person testified to these are sometimes
people who they haven't moved they've
voted in every other election and yet
mysteriously they're not on the the
rolls
let me point out that I know you read
from the blue sheets but as of 147 uh
one o'clock at 1 47 today it's what I'm
meaning to say the general court
registered 11 people in support of this
bill and 619 opposed with zero neutral I
think that's because people understand
that New Hampshire doesn't need this
bill we have a voting system that works
we have checks and balances built into
our system we want our sit in three to
participate that's the foundation of a
democracy and it's the most fundamental
right in our democracy so I urge you
please to um itl this Bill thank you
thank you any questions
representative Brennan oh I'm sorry
thank you and thank you for taking my
question I just want to go back to the
part of your testimony where you spoke
about measuring
um disenfranchisement yes
um
is it your testimony that this bill
would have a chilling effect on voter
participation
yes I I believe it would and I think
that there are
you know if you look back at some of the
testimony for example in sb3 and the
court case set ensued with that case we
did have people testifying about
different restrictions that get put in
place that can discourage voters
um from voting so
I I think that
having talked with many many people many
voters over 25 years at the doors I know
that people worry about the process of
voting and they don't want to commit a
crime that's the last thing in the world
that people want to do when it comes to
voting so they want to do what they need
to do and they want to do it correctly
and most of the time they try to bring
the documents that they need but
sometimes life intervenes and it makes
it impossible and I would be very sad if
there were voters in our community and I
don't care if they're Democrats I don't
care if they're Republicans or
independents I want those who are
qualified to vote in my community to be
able to come in and share in that
process so that we can get a sense of
what our electorate wants so I have no
interest in limiting anybody who's
qualified to vote from being able to
vote thank you any other questions
with that thank you thank you I now call
Liz tantarelli
thank you Mr chair and the committee for
this opportunity to speak I'm Liz
tentarelli I'm president of the League
of Women Voters of New Hampshire
we are a non-partisan organization and
our primary mission is empowering voters
that has been our mission for 103 years
we try to explain the voting process and
the registration process in the simplest
terms possible and that becomes harder
and harder the more laws we pass we
often get calls or emails asking for
advice from would-be voters
especially after a bill like this is in
the news people ask about registering to
vote after they've just moved and they
don't have a tax bill or a utility bill
or an updated driver's license
parents ask how their eager 18 year olds
can register if they don't drive and
they have no other proof of where they
live except the parents word and the
town clerk once told me of a young man
who showed up with a birthday card in
its envelope addressed to him from his
grandma and said it was the best he
could find to prove where he lives she
accepted it
but you know for people like us with
stable homes passports drivers licenses
this bill is not an issue
but the League of Women Voters opposes
this bill on the grounds that it makes
voter registration harder for New
Hampshire residents that it gets rid of
affidavits to prove qualifications
affidavits which have been used
successfully for at least a decade and
it puts the voter last in the interests
of the law it raises conspiracy theories
of widespread illegal voting which have
never been supported by evidence above
the goal of a representative government
in which all eligible voters have a
voice I want to address three points of
bad policy about the use of affidavits
in this bill
on page 2 lines 15 and 20 section I
it talks about reasonable documentation
about domicile
and what I highlighted in my testimony
for you says that a written statement
from a person who is listed as the owner
of the property where someone lives
is is appropriate
documentation signed by that person
under penalty of voter fraud
there's an example where we're going to
take someone else's word a signed
document as verification but we won't
take the signed document the Affidavit
of the person registering to vote
himself now I'm glad this option this
option exists to get proof from a
property owner or property manager my
20-something grandson is is moving this
weekend in fact for a new job in a new
city New State
and um you know he's moving in with
several guys he doesn't have anything to
prove he lives there yet he'll
eventually have something but he's not
got a utility bill
I don't know how he's going to do it at
least he's got some time before the next
election low-income people who couch
surf have nothing to prove where they
live and elderly people might like my
neighbor's mother move in with their
grown children and they never get
utility bills or a lease in their own
names
so at least they had the option of
getting someone to vouch for them why
can they not sign an affidavit on their
own why will we not believe them
now on page two lines 34 and 35
um
we talk about
challenges to voters you know that that
the presumptions may be defeated by
evidence establishing it's more likely
than not that the applicant is not
qualified I've never seen so many
negatives in one sentence
but anyway it goes on eventually on page
eight on lines 1 through 23 to talk
about the affidavit signed by a
challenger so you're going to take an
affidavit from someone who wants to
challenge a voter as being unqualified
but you won't take an affidavit by the
would-be voter
whose interests are here
the voter who has the right to register
and vote or other people
decide you've got to figure this out
and finally
representative Lynn alluded to the part
at the end where if on Election Day
somebody is challenged and the moderator
isn't sure what to do about this and
says well I don't think you should vote
that that person then has the right to
go to superior court that day to find a
judge willing to hear the case to
somehow round up that paperwork and then
scoop back to the polls and be given a
ballot
really
thank you
any questions
with that thank you thank you I now call
Mackenzie Saint Germain
she said three minutes let's see
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Mackenzie Saint-Germain I'm
the campaign director for the New
Hampshire campaign for voting rights
which is a project of America votes New
Hampshire I'm here today in opposition
to HB 460. our New Hampshire elections
are safe secure and accurate voters have
really high levels of confidence in our
elections after the 2022 election 91 of
those polled in a UNH poll so that they
were confident that our election results
were accurately counted and granite
theaters have good reason to be
confident in our elections we have an
accessible and secure same-day
registration process where voters do
prove their identity age citizenship and
domicile when registering right now they
do so by either providing documents
proving those things or by signing a
legal document under oath called
affidavit these are legal documents they
have serious penalties and it's
important to note also that they are
reviewed by the Secretary of State's
office and if needed the Attorney
General so those documents don't just go
away after they're used they are looked
into
this Builder moved that affidavit system
which is the only system that exists for
granite Staters who do not have or
forget any of the requirement acquired
documents to be able to exercise their
right to vote and it really isn't
difficult to find voters who have
registered using affidavits no I'm one
of probably many in this room
um I registered to vote as an 18 year
old in high school I had a free period
And I went down to the cafeteria to
register and vote in our town elections
I had my ID with me as an 18 year old
who had a driver's license but I did not
have anything to show my citizenship I
didn't have a passport and I was not
carrying around my birth certificate
which I think my parents had in a
firebox under lock and key so I signed
an affidavit to show that I was a U.S
citizen there's other countless stories
like mine um and I know they've been
talked about quite a bit today so
instead I wanted to take a moment to
discuss how unnecessary this legislation
is especially in the light of the
special committee on voter confidence
um the Secretary of State put together
last year and the New Hampshire campaign
for voting rights really closely
followed they had over 37 hours of
meetings and public testimony
um so and it was you know a bipartisan
group and they had both folks come in
from across the state and a presentation
by the Attorney General's office so I
wanted to just look back through the
report today and wanted to share some of
their findings which were created
through bipartisan consensus and I think
paint a really good picture about why
this bill is not necessary so they
include that most New Hampshire voters
have confidence in our elections New
Hampshire elections are accurate and
testimony from the Attorney General's
office and others supports this finding
there's no evidence of widespread
election fraud in New Hampshire
same day registration facilitates the
ease of voting
ongoing efforts are needed to serve all
voters state and local election
officials should make continuous efforts
so all voters feel respected and
included in the voting process including
people with disabilities foreign
language speaking voters and members of
marginalized communities and their
conclusion they said they're only rare
and isolated incidence of fraud checks
and balances are in place to deter and
prevent such occurrences and processes
exist to investigate in correct errors
when they occur these findings are
really clear that New Hampshire
elections are accurate they are free of
widespread fraud and this bill is really
ins answer in search of a problem that
does not exist New Hampshire voters have
really high confidence in our elections
and there are already important checks
and processes to ensure that our
elections continue to be accessible and
accurate the only thing that HP 460 will
do is disenfranchise voters not improve
our elections thank you and I am happy
to take any questions thank you we have
any questions
Catherine thank you Mr chairman
uh my question is when you registered to
vote did you register to vote in New
Hampshire and if so was their follow-up
on that citizenship uh so I did register
to vote in New Hampshire I know from
being involved that the Secretary of
State's office looks into that process
there was not personal follow-up for me
on my citizenship
um I used my New Hampshire driver's
license was all I had with me
thank any other questions
thank you
I now call and I don't want to butcher
the last name Henry from the ACLU
people need to learn how to print
I've been getting that since
kindergarten
um good afternoon my name is Henry
clementowicz I'm a lawyer with the
American civil liberties Union of New
Hampshire
I've been involved in probably the last
five or six pieces of election law
litigation in New Hampshire and other
people have talked about this bill so
I'm I really just want to make three
quick points if I may
first I wanted to let the committee know
how many people would be affected by
this bill
according to a right to know request
response from the Secretary of State in
at the general election so that's a
midterm election
739 voters use the qualified voter
affidavit to prove citizenship
219 voters use the qualified voter
affidavit to prove identity in 1643
voters use the domicile affidavit so
that's about 25 100 people in a midterm
election who would potentially be not
able to vote if this Bill had been law
at the time because they would not have
been allowed to register uh not having
those documents we've also been talking
about this bill largely as a voter ID
bill and I think it's worth pointing out
that one of the more pernicious aspects
of this bill is the way that it treats
citizenship which is I in my opinion the
the qualification for voting that's most
difficult to prove
um the statute and I know representative
Barry isn't here but uh I did get an
answer to his question both under
current law and on under this proposed
Bill reasonable proof of of citizenship
is allowed the problem is that other
than a birth certificate and a passport
and Naturalization paper there really
aren't other documents that people have
to prove citizenship you don't need to
be a United States citizen to get a
driver's license in New Hampshire or in
Most states so that's that's not proof
you really need either a birth
certificate or a passport
it costs a hundred and ten dollars to
get a new passport book and routine
service takes 10 to 12 weeks the time
and cost to acquire a birth certificate
depends on where you're born in New
Hampshire a birth certificate costs 15
but if you are an American who is born
abroad and thus a natural born American
uh it requires fifty dollars and a
notarized request to the state
department I I can only assume uh that
that process is pretty time intensive
too and those are the only ways that you
can prove citizenship that's probably
why in 2020 the 10th circuit in a case
called fish versus Schwab struck down a
similar Kansas laws unconstitutional uh
finding that uh the state's requirement
for what they call documentary proof of
citizenship the state's interests were
insufficiently waiting to justify the
limitations on the right to vote imposed
by that requirement and in 2020 the
Supreme Court decline cert so that's the
last case I was able to find it's two
years old
saying that this type of citizenship
proof requirement is unconstitutional
finally I just want to hit on the
challenges again
um
I respectfully I differ from
representative Lynn in terms of what
this bill would do to challenges I think
the biggest change is that under current
law if a voter is challenged and the
challenge is well grounded they're
allowed to vote if they execute the
challenged voter affidavit that's
actually why the challenge voter
affidavit was created under this statute
however uh if it were to become law
under a well-challenged a well-founded
challenge the voter would not be allowed
to vote so basically what happens is you
have moderators and supervisors of the
checklist
using What's called the preponderance of
the evidence standard which is one of
the lowest standards we have in the law
to determine whether a person can vote
or not with I think many lacking due
process protection so there's no
guaranteed opportunity for the voter to
introduce Witnesses or evidence no
advance notice no right to an attorney
no provision for a neutral fact finder
in the event that the supervisor of the
checklist or moderator is conflicted and
no meaningful right of judicial review
representative Lin is right that this
does introduce and appeal to Superior
Court but the very the very shortest
period of time I've ever seen a court
take is in a matter of hours as noted
before the courts closed about three
hours before the polls close in Most
states and the the current cost to file
an appeal in Superior Court is 280 which
is a lot of money for someone to have to
pay if they're
um
just to vote if a challenge against them
was well deemed well-pounded so
um I'm happy to take questions
um if there are any but I I think that
there's a number of reasons why this is
better more ahead
thank you
um you your numbers on a number of
Voters uh your statistics on the numbers
of Voters who use the qualified voter
affidavit did that include people using
those affidavits who are same-day
registrants it was that's a great
question and that was
um it was anyone who executed one of
those affidavits in 2022. I assume it
was I assume but don't know that it was
mostly same-day registrants because
that's when most registrations happen I
should say you can also use the
qualified voter affidavit to prove age
which is the easiest I think
um qualification approved but the
secretary of state does not keep track
of how many people do that
and and this bill does not address
same-day voter registration is that
correct my understanding is that this
bill would have the same effects on
people regardless of when and where they
registered to vote
last one okay is this one is this bill
addresses you know RSA 65412 my
understanding is that IT addresses those
who are registering to vote
um mostly 30 days before an election not
those who are voting on the day of
election is that your understanding well
I I think it's a little bit complicated
because some of the language that was
put in this bill was drawn from the sp3
case which is currently in the statutes
but is subject to an injunction by the
courts and so I think it was kind of
reincorporating
dead law if that makes sense I'm not
sure whether the intent was to only
apply outside the 30 days but currently
New Hampshire doesn't draw that
distinction because of the New Hampshire
Democratic party versus Secretary of
State kiss thank you
let me know Howard
so uh thank you uh Mr chair and uh thank
you for taking my question uh so you you
had mentioned uh that there could be
somebody an individual who could go to a
superior court uh and file a a a a
reversal of the uh of of their ballot uh
so uh how many Courts are there in the
State uh that could hear this cave well
I think it's a the superior court and
there are 11 Superior Courts in the
state
any further questions okay thank you
thank you
I now call Matt Museum
correct me if I'm wrong
smooshian you did great thank you
uh good afternoon members of the
committee uh my name is Matt mushian I
live in Claremont where I serve as a
city councilor and today I'm here
representing 603 Ford a nonpartisan
non-profit organization dedicated to
educating activating and empowering
young people in our state
I'm here today to testify in opposition
of House Bill 460 which would eliminate
the ability to register to vote by
assigned affidavit as you've heard today
this is a bill in search of a problem
we've seen numerous studies reports and
investigations that have all confirmed
that New Hampshire elections are safe
and secure and that our existing
affidavit system works
6034 it opposes this legislation because
it will disproportionately negatively
impact the right to vote for young
voters
which is why I urge the committee to
vote in expedient to legislate on House
Bill 460.
when I was 18 uh in College at New
England College I wanted to register and
vote in the election just like anybody
else but all I had with me was my state
issued driver's license which would not
count as proof of citizenship
luckily I was able to sign an affidavit
to prove that I was a citizen and I was
able to cast my ballot under this new
proposed legislation I would have not
been able to sign the affidavit and I
would have been turned away without
voting
the problem is that this legislation
doesn't just attack the right to vote
for young voters and student voters but
also new Americans people experiencing
homelessness and the elderly
I've worked at my local polling location
before and I've seen how common it can
be for someone to forget or to simply
not have a proper proof they need but
I've also seen how hard our election
officials work to keep our elections
safe and secure
you've heard them today and there are
legitimate concerns about House Bill 460
and its impact on granite Staters
exercising their constitutional right to
vote and this committee should listen
and take heat of them
furthermore this body should be
prioritizing policies like implementing
an online voter registration becoming a
member state of the electronic
registration information Set uh
Center and really dedicate its focus to
making more secure while efficient
elections for people to participate and
what is the Bedrock of our democracy are
free and fair elections so I ask you
please vote and expedient to legislate
on how to spell 460.
and I I can't take questions because I
have to run back for city council
meeting thank you so thank you
I now call Lucas Meyer
uh good afternoon chairman members of
the committee I'll keep this brief my
name is Lucas Meyer I live in Manchester
New Hampshire I'm here representing
myself but I am also the co-founder and
board chair of 603 forward I just hope
it is not lost on the committee that
today there is a special election in
Rochester where SB 418 for the first
time is being implemented no shorter
than a week in change after that
guidance was sent to local election
officials I think we look at the intent
of this bill about improving voter
confidence and we look at the good work
that the Secretary of State's committee
on voter confidence did over the summer
and the emphasis that was placed on
supporting our local election officials
and ceasing this game of moving the goal
posts on them year after year
I think is really striking when you
consider the sponsor of this bill was
also the sponsor of SB 418 and he is now
looking to change what has already
implemented an SB 418 just a year later
and today the day that law is first
being put into place so I think that is
important context as we have this
conversation secondly we look to the
intent of this bill and the purpose of
this bill which assuming best intentions
which I will indulge for the moment is
to improve voter confidence in New
Hampshire elections the supposition is
that there is perhaps not recorded but
voter fraud or voter impropriety
happening in New Hampshire and that we
need more data to find it we just had
the ACLU testify to the raw numbers of
folks who'd be disenfranchised by this
but we don't have data about what some
of the sponsors theorize for what there
is for improper voting in New Hampshire
and I would urge this committee that if
that is the sincere purpose and intent
to find in the state
cases of possible voter fraud that this
committee make a movement for New
Hampshire to join the electronic
registration information center and
let's apply some real data to this
debate
if you look at where a majority of
out-of-state IDs are used to register in
the state usually same day and you look
at the member states of Eric the
electronic registration information
center there is a striking overlap
between those States meaning after an
election New Hampshire along with 32
other States including Washington DC
would be able to receive a report
for anyone who had moved out of state to
New Hampshire
or within New Hampshire's border or who
had died or changed address and we would
have that information sent to us so we
would no longer have to wonder who is
this person who showed up same day maybe
they voted in Massachusetts too we would
have the data
to show everybody in this state if that
was true or not now I am a particular
proponent of this as a voting rights
Advocate because I would like to put
some data down on paper let's have an
honest debate about what is happening in
this state and let's look
at what's happening now
we can do this we actually don't have to
pass a bill to join Eric the Secretary
of State could do that himself today uh
I do not often agree with the governor
of Florida on issues of voting rights
but I do agree with him that their that
joining Eric is a smart thing for a
state to do which is why Republican
states and Democratic states have joined
it so before we yet again
seek to confuse and complicate the same
day voter registration process because
last year it was 4 18 this year it is
this bill next year it will be a
different bill just to get rid of it
entirely
before we have that debate let's join
Eric let's add some confidence to our
elections let's stop moving the goal
post on our local election officials
must have an honest conversation about
this
thank you
any questions
good thank you thank you
last card
Mr David Trumbull
I do without my glasses
good afternoon thank you my name is
David Trumbull I'm from where in New
Hampshire
I was a candidate for State Rep this
past term I did not win but I'm still
very interested in the issues going
forward I'm opposed to this bill for
three reasons first voting is a
fundamental right and it's not just any
old fundamental right it's the
fundamental right that upholds every
other single right that we have this is
from a case that was mentioned earlier
today Harper versus the Virginia State
Board of Elections U.S Supreme Court
1966 Justice Douglas he said that the
court referred to voting as a
fundamental political right especially
since the right to exercise the
franchise in a free and unimpaired
manner is preservative of other basic
civil and political rights any alleged
infringement of the right of citizens to
vote must be carefully and meticulously
scrutinized so if you want to pass this
bill today you have to have it be
definitely proven that there's a need
for this bill and the testimony has been
that there is no need for this bill the
second reason I impose this bill is that
New Hampshire is the most difficult
state to vote in in the United States
there is a survey that is done every
year and updated it's called the cost of
voting in the American states and it's
reported in the election Law Journal in
September of 2022 they wrote this
Mississippi in 49th Place in New
Hampshire 50th stay at the bottom of the
rankings as the most difficult States
for voting their failure to move is
large moving up the rankings is largely
due to these states failing to keep Pace
with reforms like online voter
registration no excuse absentee voting
an automatic voter registration which
have taken place in other states we're
not keeping Pace the reason this bill
was presented in other bills like it is
to create the mindset that we have a
voting problem in the state we don't
have a problem in the state but when
bills like this come up it makes people
afraid so they're not willing to do the
things that they've done in the other
four 49 states which is things like
online voter registration and no excuse
absentee ballots it's time for us to
join the 24th Cent first century in New
Hampshire and make it easier for our
citizens to vote and lastly third is
that this bill would disenfranchise
thousands of New Hampshire voters now
the attorney from the ACLU gave you some
statistics from the uh off-year election
in 2022 go back to an article in New
Hampshire Business review and November
7th of 2021 it's a quoting from Bill
Gardner former Secretary of State he
said I don't have one example to give
you where a person won an election in
this state who should not have won it he
discussed Protections in the New
Hampshire law allowing people to
register to vote on the day of an
election those who don't have the proper
documents to prove residency and other
qualifications can sign an affidavit and
the state follows up with a verification
process through the mail about 4
thousand voters had to sign such an
affidavit in the state's primary and
general elections in 2020 of those the
state has not been able to authenticate
the voter qualifications for about 600
people although they were continuing to
work upon it that's out of eight hundred
thousand votes so Bill Gardner said
never an election in the state has voter
fraud changed an election four thousand
people would be disenfranchised by this
bill
the testimony from Louise Spencer was
that the Heritage Foundation has looked
at almost 20 years of Elections and has
found 20 cases of voter fraud in New
Hampshire that's one per election so are
you willing and we don't really know the
extent of that but one per election are
you willing to disenfranchise 4
000 residents of our state because there
may be one case of voter fraud that
really doesn't seem like a very good
trade-off because voting is how people
choose all of you who come here and
debate about policies regarding
education and health care and gun
control and abortion in every other Bill
if people can't vote they can't pick
their legislators it's fundamentally
important 4 000 people will be
disenfranchised if you vote for this
bill instead let's make it easier to
vote because we want everybody to
participate in our government thank you
very much
any questions
good thank you
foreign
of course